[Music]
we're back episode number 35 in front of
me
is it 35 somewhere around there i'm
ethan klein
with my host queen of big giant hair you
like the diet here today
is that okay can i examine what i just
want to see what's going on here oh my
goodness
it's very tight oh that's what she said
he's in
is this so now tell me what's going on
here because it was a pamela anderson
inspired look today so
she had this really big hair and i just
really liked it i thought it made me
look skinnier too i feel a little fat i
thought
dude your hair is huge
that's the biggest hair i've ever seen
is that pamela anderson
oh my god i don't know it's just big ass
hair
oh i think she's a big ass girl wait
wait wait wait so is this this isn't
real right because it looks real here
but like you don't have that much hair
dude
no yeah it's it's a wig this part on is
awake so this is real this is a wig
yeah okay turn can i see i just wanna
okay yeah that look that's a good job
that was meant to be like that it was
like a look it was where they put the
wig in the back you are
the queen of big hair today and i feel
like little hair
you have no hair but you look very
skinny do i mm-hmm you look
have you been trying to lose weight i
haven't been trying it's my whole
[ __ ] life
we said you had a cheat day friday so i
didn't yeah fridays are my cheeks that's
your only dream but i'm responsible
what'd you eat what did i eat on friday
italian you said oh you know what i did
date i didn't eat
all day in preparation for my children
oh i was like extra good so i didn't eat
all day and then we went out
we actually went out because we're both
fully vaccinated [ __ ]
god blessed so that's how you said so we
went out to eat an italian restaurant it
was really nice what'd you have
i got some like lamb like a lamb on a
bone and it was like falling off the
bone with mashed potatoes i was like oh
shh that's what you get at an italian
restaurant is lamb yeah they telling us
know how to do it man they do everything
yeah you don't like pasta that's the one
thing we disagree and i like love pasta
pasta's a waste of calories
that's all i eat i know that's offensive
to some people so with peace and love i
say this
pasta is a waste of calories i mean if
i'm going out there trying to
you know eat 3 000 calories pasta is
like the last thing i want
that's all i want i'd be so skinny if i
didn't eat pasta
and drink that well this is my fuel and
i have i have
thank you for buying for providing a
nice workplace where you provide food
for us
because honestly i didn't eat this
morning it's not that glamorous
this is from you guys most like don't
worry i'll get something in their house
and i felt really bad about it like i
don't i hate eating other people's foods
but i was so starving so i haven't eaten
anything this morning and so i was very
hungry and i see what you're drinking
today
yeah this is a this is the same thing i
always drink you always want to know
what i drink
we've got here today oh there's no
coupon or a coupon there's no
tag no so what is this it's a caramel
frappuccino with extra caramel drizzle
have you ever had it you want some no i
can't drink this [ __ ] that's like 600
calories it's not weight loss food it's
not even that i'm more worried about
like diabetes because it runs my family
oh yeah first thing i had this morning
so oh yeah yeah you're going to lose
your legs
for sure all right that happened my
uncle joe
yeah he lost his feet i'm worried about
diabetes too that's one of the reasons
why
i'm like okay i cannot get fatter
because i just i really don't want to be
diabetic yeah we already worry about
diabetes so i don't need the internet
worrying for me i hate when people are
like oh we're worried about trash it's
like i worry about me i don't need
everyone
to worry about no i know what you mean
you know i mean but you should know that
diabetes isn't just from sugar it's
about
excess it's about like when you have
excessive body fat
and you consume too much calories it's
not about sugar actually
it's not about consumption of sugar it's
just the calories yeah but
diabetes ironically i'm like we could go
to a doctor and do a physical i'm pretty
like healthy with like
clothes that would be a good episode
who has the best physical oh my god
would you do that i think i have a
really good one because i always go and
they're always like your cholesterol is
great and like your blood pressure's low
i'm sure they say that they're like
trisha they're like trisha keep
it up we should go next week because i'm
not kidding i get physicals all the
freaking time because you want
that thing on my neck i went and did
like so many physicals and like oh yeah
that was i went to an ears yeah it was
like two like centimeters and so he was
just like oh you should probably come
back like
and get it biopsied but i was like uh oh
you should definitely if you thought
you'd get a biopsy you'd get a biopsy
what are you waiting for i just don't
like needles oh you're gonna like you're
gonna hate cancer a lot more
yeah no would you please get that back i
know i'm not doing the show unless you
schedule that um we are not doing
another episode on hiatus right now
find a different doctor i'm not i am not
doing this show another episode until
you get that biopsy
what are we going to do now schedule it
well we could do this show over here
okay i'm serious okay i'll get it done
i promise you've got to show me proof
that you scheduled it before the next
episode um how do i do that
i think that's like um invasion of like
legal privacy rights i don't think i
should disclose medical information with
people
all right no calling hr no your
information you could disclose it to me
i think i'm fine honestly i don't want
it okay cool show's over
god i'm serious it's ridiculous you said
you need you have a lung
you have a soft tissue line it's not
gone he told you to get a biopsy the
doctor said get a biopsy
he's not god god told me you're gonna
put that there so god's trying to kill
you he's trying to save you
i was gonna go to church yesterday and
it didn't happen but
next week god's like saw that i wish we
had orange chicken right now i'm so
hungry i hadn't eaten this morning
[ __ ] are these kosher pretzels
i mean what's on well i don't know what
would be on kosher about a pretzel
did like this was uh the dough was
needed with pork blood
i don't even know what kosher means what
makes something kosher well
besides like there are certain things
like dairy and meat aren't supposed to
mix and pork is unkosher
but you also have to get it blessed by a
rabbi when this bunch of [ __ ]
oh so you don't keep kosher me
never oh okay no dude moses [ __ ]
eating bacon like a goddamn save his
life
isn't kosher either why because i look
like a pig
i didn't say that can we be miss piggy
and kermit the frog dude i wanted to
suggest that but i don't want to be
offensive
offensive to me i don't know since
lately i've always i've kind of been
holding back a little bit
i felt like it was mean to say you look
like miss piggy
i love her i do think you look like miss
piggy and you have her swag
too thank you you have piggy swag i love
that
yeah i think that's iconic she's
psychotic and i'm kind of like kermit
miss piggy who's a better kermit
impression here with kermit the frog
here
go your turn i i haven't listened to
kermit in a while
okay okay hello it's kermit the frog
here
this is better hold on
hey oh my god hold on let me listen to
kermit
woke up and chose negativity today
hold on let me play let me play kermit
so i just can get a sense for his voice
[ __ ] jim henson he's dead what's he
gonna do about it oh my god
i don't know i'm just saying if his
ghost wants to come copper on my claim
i'll have a
issue with him and his family didn't he
die of diabetes for real
no are you sure no he oh you know how he
died not listening to doctors
didn't he have some like minor [ __ ]
infection and he was like a christian
scientist he didn't believe in doctors
and he just dropped that
i don't know that aspect of it but i do
but i do know it was a a minor a
relatively minor ailment yeah he didn't
listen to doctors
and he died very suddenly yeah [ __ ]
they're like yeah dude just take this uh
medicine you'll be fine he's like [ __ ]
that i kind of want to die suddenly
though i don't want to
drag it out no what okay okay what is
that
what is that cool we're getting to
dreams are how we figure out where we
want to go how now we figure out where
we want to go
oh that's pretty good it was life
is how we get there life is how we get
there
excuse me hmm that's like i feel like
that's a different generation that was
piggy
oh that was pretty oh yeah yeah that one
was good give me a piggy give me a piggy
yeah that's really good mr frog
piggy could you please bob on my knob
bob i will not bob on your knob miss
piggy could you kindly
[ __ ] off you obnoxious [ __ ] that's what
he wants to say not what i feel about
you
you can't just say that using like a
curve like it's funny
we have a lot to get to should we talk
oh we didn't even say thank you to our
sponsors
omaze and honey we did omaze we're doing
an omaze tesla giveaway
simply to stick it to david literally
that's why we're doing it
i was like i don't know what to say to
that that's it that's why
maybe we just want to give people a
tesla that's cool it's cool that he gave
people tesla's everything else is bad
but tesla's are kind of cool
well whatever it is i just i don't
listen i'm doing it to stick it to david
if you guys want to participate that's
your thing but i thought it'd be funny
if we gave away tesla
yeah and we're giving away to people who
like our dessert it's not just like
we're giving away to rich youtubers
we're like giving away to someone who
like maybe needs it you know was he just
giving it to rich
yeah like jason he gave him a tesla oh
really oh they're like hey
right these people can afford their own
car yeah yeah yeah people were like why
and then one person he gave two cars to
like a lamborghini and a tesla
were like oh and it was a youtuber that
makes a lot of money and i'm like
well it's all sponsored it's not like he
even bought the [ __ ] cars we bought
we did not buy this car oh no
i'm not gonna pretend like i paid for
[ __ ] they're paying me they're paying us
i mean they're paying us this is not
this is not generosity i'm getting paid
fully for this
do i yeah of course okay yep you know 50
50.
is it yeah yeah sponsors of 50 50. i
don't even know
um top of the show guys okay we've got a
bunch of memes today we're going to talk
about how keemstar is the worst
human being alive it's been an
uneventful week and weekend
well that's not true though jeff the
jeff whittick documentaries had me
really interested
we're going to talk about that and then
we're going to do trivia
okay we're doing trivia are you smarter
than a fifth grader but we added a
category to make it more fair to you we
added a pop culture
category and we made it expansive as
possible wait why is there different
trivia oh there's like science trivia
well last time you were complaining
about the categories so we added one
wait is this are you smarter than a
fifth grader again or is it it's just
i mean that's just stick but it's trivia
no but one time we determined it was
just pop culture
this is this is a breath of categories
i got it less excited
i'm excited okay good i just wish i
should have eaten i'm so mad i didn't do
you want to eat do you want to pause
you're really bothered that you haven't
eat no it's good that i'm hungry
i got pretzels i'm fine we better get
this girl damn
we gotta get her a pizza or something
stat we are trying yeah
okay you look great
do you really mean that really really
skinny i'm so
happy for you i weighed myself i finally
did it
i think it's good i think i'm definitely
losing pounds but what depressed me is
how hot like i know i've lost weight
but i didn't realize how much weight i
had gained well you're only like 2 20 or
something you said right
no what were you i mean that's what i
said but the truth is actually i
the truth is i think i was at 2 40 and
now i'm at 2 30. i think i'm at 2 40. i
don't know
i'm just guessing but i was like because
i was like okay no i've lost weight i'm
just gonna get on the scale and it said
2 30 i was like
holy [ __ ] i know i can't i can't like
look at this i gotta like actually start
losing weight and then look at the scale
yeah i don't it's just depressing but
you know what's sad is like when i was
200 i thought i was fat
oh yeah i was like oh my god i had 30
pounds still i'm fat again
yeah when i was on crack i thought i was
fat but i was so skinny
that's what i need to start doing
smoking crack more regularly
instead of just recreationally once in a
while i think i injected a crack can you
even do that i think that's what i did
i think you can inject anything someone
injected it for me how was it
crack was not good not good that made me
like that's when i was out of it for
like a month
i think i had covered when i had crack
when i did crack you did a cover crack
binge
yeah it was the summer of 2019 so i
think i was one of the first coat
because honestly like
i lost my my taste for like two months
and i had cloven
but it could have been the crack it
could have been the crack it could have
been the covenant i mean who really
knows is that a new game
is it crackers i'll play that game we
have a category for that
is this trisha on crack or coved
you ain't cullen yeah you saw me after i
did my crack covered binge when i was
when i did the bachelor in the first
episode where i was like announcing it i
was on a crack covered binge
i didn't know that the more you know
so wait you were on a binge or you just
did crack once or you did it several
times i was on it for like
10 days straight with somebody oh you
were just on a crack bin they like came
to my house and we just like
were you having sex and stuff or what
was the point of like what was the drive
was it i don't remember him he was so
skinny i remember him carrying me to the
bathtub to like get me to like bathe
because like i could not do it and he
was so skinny and i was
i was getting skinnier i lost about 20
pounds in like a week that's what i'm
saying dude smoke crack ladies and
gentlemen
yeah okay well let's here someone first
of all let's let's leave the crack
uh on the shelf for later somebody put
together an edit of all of your
lookalikes
oh my god here's you as bono
that's crazy though is that me or wait
i'm confused whose picture is that
though
no that's an unedited photo of bono
he's not wearing makeup no that's him my
face on
and then here's samuel jackson okay i
see candid photo
looks just like you know they didn't
they didn't here's adam sandler
no i don't see that one as much i don't
think i yeah no i don't see that one
here's jack black
my favorite if they would have just done
our real faces you would see that i
looked like him they tried to make him
look crazy
they're trying to pull out the likeness
is all
i see it ah i look like jack black and
kung fu panda that's the one i feel like
you look like a panda or i think i just
look like
jack black the most maybe maybe bono
though that one was close i honestly
didn't know who was i honestly think you
look the most like samuel jackson
i was told that when i was really young
that was like my first one i got
i feel like that's the most interesting
comparison did you know elon musk was
hosting snl on my birthday
are you coming to my birthday party i
didn't know you i wasn't invited no one
has been yet it's under 20 people
so am i coming your birthday party i
don't know it's up to you am i invited
i have a nice car i want a bear you're
in then um
yeah you know what's so weird but i'm so
nervous well am i invited or not
i don't know are you who's at your party
that i'm gonna run into it's like under
20 people it's like not that many
is it like just family no no it's like
my parties are like work parties it's
always my like people that work for me
throughout the year it's like the one
time like that's the only friends i have
so it's like my hair stylist my music
video director my choreographer like
they just all come and solve for my
birthday because i have no friends
i mean i want to come i want to come
celebrate your birthday you will yeah
we have karaoke it's great
do you have like why do you say that dan
you've talked about on the show that you
hate
karaoke don't you i don't remember i
mean if you're drunk you don't remember
anything i feel like every time you're
on like
look i stand here i'm talking all week
who can keep track of all the things i
say here
i mean that's true when people are like
you don't remember something from 2016.
i'm like i say a lot of [ __ ] and i don't
yeah
i'm talking all the time i don't keep
track of what i say
well yeah yeah listen okay
yeah why wouldn't i be invited why are
you even considering like not inviting
me i don't know how you guys are i don't
want to send the imitation okay when
people invite me to stuff i don't want
to go but then you're like oh no i'm
super awkward because someone invited me
i don't want to go cause i feel like you
guys are such homebodies
if i don't want to go i won't go okay
cool
i won't feel like obligated i feel like
we have a we have a
strong enough relationship probably like
nah well you also know moses i'm like oh
maybe you don't know anyone would you
know moses
yeah he's my brother-in-law known him
for a long time so you'll know him i've
known him actually incidentally much
longer than you have
isn't that interesting yeah fascinating
well yeah because you're married yeah
yeah um well you know what it is to have
my birthday like no one knows each other
it's all it's always like one person
from each walk of my life so no one
knows
they all kind of come together and
they're like oh i know you from churches
parties
yeah i don't know people and then i
maybe it'd be weird because everyone's
like oh you're the guy from frenemies
talk to me
and i'll be like no thanks no i don't
think anyone
watches front of me that i know really
no isn't that weird
i feel like everyone's going to be just
like being they'll be like oh my god
it's ethan
my mom and sister really love you they
love friend of mine they do that's nice
i like when the family likes me it's
rare
it's very rare okay so
um james charles hit the clearance rack
finally i thought you might enjoy this
that someone saw him in some cosmetics
story on the clearance rack
is it real apparently i don't know
selling it on the website
yeah yeah i know the shady [ __ ] dude
it's like it's like i said
it's like if bill cosby after all this
[ __ ] went down he's in prison
and they're still selling jello and
pudding with bill cosby like get the
pudding get the boy it's like no that
[ __ ] would be off the racks
james charles is a predator we're
talking about does a dozen victims
get him off the [ __ ] shelves well
we're get him out where's his at maybe
we can just go and like trash it
put it in the trash ourselves i have no
idea you don't know what this is how do
you i don't know where it is can you
tell here
triangulate this car and uh the the
power poles wait it's outside i'm so
confused
i was at ultra someone said i don't know
what ultra is ultra music festival
okay sorry it's far away me neither
clearly
anyway i thought you would enjoy that um
i don't care about anything james this
is gonna be like a five hour episode but
i know
uh i wish we could do five hours don't
you know sometimes i wish
but youtube really hate it don't worry i
do this like the only social hour it's
the only time i see someone
outside of mo that's why i like love but
it's like my soul shower it's like i
feel like we get together and just
gossip for five hours like i see you
next week
yeah because sometimes we like go way
off the path with our conversations and
i like it but i'm like oh we got trivia
and we got these things to talk about so
i don't know if i should just let it
just like let the ride ride i like how
you have direction
yeah you do good i also feel that like
yeah sometimes people
get mad at me just like stop trying to
keep trisha on the rail
they want me off the rails they want it
off the rails oh okay
but they also want trivia you know what
i'm saying i want trivia too
here's trisha cutting uh chicken that
was frustrating a lot of people
they're saying it drives them crazy
watching you cut chicken now i have to
agree you're not cutting the chicken
you're not you're not even cutting it in
half like watch when you flip it like
what are
what are you doing and by the way this
is the person who beat me in a cooking
contest so [ __ ] my life
i killed him um i don't even know girl
look how you cut it like
you flip it
[Laughter]
i think you're just supposed to perform
the cut
you're not even applying pressure really
i think i'm scared i like cut my fingers
off that's why i don't like doing him i
don't know
i think it's okay got the job done what
am i making i don't even know what i'm
making there
i don't like cooking competition take
two i can't
relive that moment
what is our next competition today
but i mean like real competition you
mean the one where you're not you're not
destined to for sure lose i mean i kill
trivia every time we should trigger
the place you lost and today you're
gonna lose big time here's trisha
cooking without the fire on
again she beat me uh she beat me in
cooking
she's cooking eggs and the fire isn't on
i told you i've never cooked i don't
know
so here you have it and she beat me in
cooking where is this from
literally these eggs literally these
eggs are not cooking
maybe check the stove
[Music]
oh my god trisha oh my god
that is the gas smell holy cow that's
why they weren't cooking
genius i've never cooked i told you i
never i used to never cook before we
went into this new house had a cool
kitchen and i was like all right it's
time for me to cook
um one other thing i wanted to point out
is that okay this
the oscars were on last night and they
got only 10 million viewers
whoa so that's the oscar tanks the
steamies what are we at
steam's ahead i'm saying next year
stevie's passes the oscars
2022 for sure are we are we doing a live
event
i think we yeah it's gonna take some
planning but yeah i think we're gonna do
it
do you think anyone's gonna show up i do
i think we're gonna sell out no i mean
like presenters
are we're the presenter is maybe like if
you say like let's say hypothetically
um most uh let's say
greatest breakdown greatest middle
breakdown i don't think they're going to
show up
well let's say but they might like let's
say gabby hannah is nominated for
greatest mental breakdown
she might show up to accept no comment
and i mean that would be great i would
definitely i would present her
and then i can see us getting a little
argument during her acceptance
and then we could play her off we can
play the music that's like okay
player off yeah sounds good
i i wish her well no combat no problem
oh just an example yeah i feel bad for
him are we gonna get a hypnotist
i i am a food addict for sure actually
you know what i get
i try to get hypnotized for this show
dan write that down
i mean ian write that down i want a
hypnotist and
i want to get a physical test i want to
get physical tests me and trisha
for sure yeah i mean it can be
triggering i mean i'm fine with it but
i'm saying
have you like on camera get like your
physical red i'm fine with it
you feel like you're about your blood
sugar level is 100
sugar but like who wins in that
competition like if you have the higher
blood cholesterol like i want or is it
the person with like the
no the healthier person wins and then
what do they win a pizza
10 years of longer life ugh you can take
it
i don't really want to live that long
okay let's talk so 50
maybe 50 that's all you're aiming for
yeah
okay you're on track someone gonna kill
me
no i think you're on track to die at 50.
thank you that's what you're aiming for
i just don't want to die before moses i
keep thinking i'm going to die like he's
going to die before me and i asked the
other day i was like if you die before
me who do i call to help me with
everything like who's going to take care
of that
he's like you need three different
people you need someone take care of the
house you need someone to take care of
you you need
uh he said gigolo
he like seriously i don't know what i'd
do if he died like i would i would just
crumble
would you hire a gigolo because you
don't want to get into another
relationship but you do have needs i
don't think i'd ever have sex again if
moses signed he's
really just abstinence forever i would
feel like he'd haunt me if i was like
having sex with someone and he'd like
comment like
would you haunt her if she had sex with
somebody oh
yes he said yes he'll haunt you he's
super chill i was trying to do a
tick-tock you know there's a trend now
it's like
shake that ass and it's like you show
somebody that's gonna shake your ass i
see them about you i see people be like
have you seen those no they're like i
don't take math for anyone and then they
go to like you and it says like shake
your [ __ ]
me yeah i got them to shake their eyes
oh boy
you get a lot of people are really
standing you on tick tock as far as like
being a sex symbol people are very like
ethan daddy can get it daddy couldn't
get it that's not cool do you ever see
those i think that's so cool i always
want to send them to be like look people
think you're attractive send them to me
i don't see them
really we see them all the time people
are really big ethan stands on there
why don't i see him where's my home why
is my feet failing me i need the car
what is it
like james charles and stuff that's why
i like weird my feed is like is like
white a
white claw game going [ __ ] baby it's
wednesday i deserve fried chicken
literally no idea who that is let me
show you really it's hot as a mother
down here isn't it
your house is always hot i'm always
dying uh yeah white clock gabe here let
me show you he's my new favorite tick
tucker
what stop it what is it no what are you
using white cloth gabe
he's a legend on tick dock that's a
jewish name he's probably jewish
he's 100 not jewish right really
oh i don't know maybe it's not
here can you lick me the fro well hero
let me just pull him up this is my man
yankees win baby [ __ ]
yeah yankees win baby [ __ ]
what that's why claw gabe he's just
putting out his message to the world
why is he what yeah i was like i'm
trying i don't know it's 4
20. shout outs to the wheat smokers
[ __ ] [ __ ]
smoke that weed baby it's [ __ ] 4 20.
yes right
dude cursing okay time for education for
trisha
cursing uh is the rarest one of the
it's extremely rare that someone with
tourette's actually manifests by
vocalizing cursing extremely rare i look
at trouts on tick tock and they do that
all the time
whatever you see on tick tock is not
reality i'm just telling you the cursing
thing is extremely rare
it's like less than one percent of
people with tourette's have that
condition [ __ ]
i'm ready to see this there's something
okay yeah i agree he probably has some
thing but it's not a [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] bunny can you just enjoy
the video why do you need to diagnose
his mental illness or like try to be
like oh he's got to always
i just enjoy the specs with his white
claw gabe this guy's living his best
life and you're out here trying to
pinpoint what's wrong with him there's
nothing wrong with he's a beautiful soul
i'm ready to see those [ __ ] boys and
money [ __ ] i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm not a pudding but it's like
aggressive and i'm just trying to figure
out what's wrong with them
because someone's gonna look at that and
think that's normal behavior and they're
gonna try and emulate it it's not normal
nobody thinks it's normal tricia
guess what time is it yeah thursday
night five o'clock in the [ __ ]
dot baby
[ __ ] yeah baby [ __ ] let's drink baby
thursday night five o'clock yeah the
weekend eve baby
friday eve baby [ __ ] yeah it's the eve
of the weekend [ __ ] yeah
thursday night white cause baby [ __ ]
yeah that's why club gabe and that's my
whole homepage
in case you're wondering i am sweating i
am dripping your house is always
the pal i think our ac is all hold on i
need i need a moment
okay it's so hot in here okay so uh
we'll sew to a break when we come back
we're going to be talking about keemstar
the worst human being
on youtube maybe the world and jack and
jill
adam sandler costumes potentially whoa
that is not what i expected to talk
about what i was just trying to lead the
conversation to
another direction we're going oh you
want to talk about you want to do jack
and jill yeah
wow i just thought of my phone i want to
you should be jill and i'll be jack
because i have his costume from jack and
jill
i hate that movie it's one of the worst
movies ever made it's insult to
movie watchers and it's in salt it's an
insult
we'll talk about when we get back they
literally ruined al pacino's legacy
or enhanced it with a double chino you
know they had him doing a song
of course it's a nightmare it's etched
on my brain jack and jill worst movie
ever
uh let's go to a break we'll be right
back
honey is great and it's back at it again
we were talking about if we should do
that for a whole minute and just end it
we should probably explain more maybe
though yeah yeah honey is great and it's
free do you like to shop online we all
do why are you not downloading honey in
just two easy steps
to get discounts to get money back free
app do it now honey ethan
what else do you love about honey okay
do you shop online i shop online
and if you're like me you always want to
make sure like dude i know there's a
coupon out there
that's going to save me like a bunch of
money on this purchase but you're lazy
yeah and then also like these code
websites are such a nightmare you're
like this one doesn't work but that what
do you do
no honey does it all for you
automatically does the work for you go
to your favorite website i'm talking
about over 30
000 stores online ranging from you know
gaming
fashion food delivery everything once
you get to the checkout honey goes
hold on [ __ ] i'm stepping in is she i
like to say that honey is like your dad
that clips coupons by the fire every
night
right that's you doing the but without
the trauma
i imagine honey saying here beautiful
here's a coupon
here's sweetheart yeah here honey have a
coupon
so when you go to the cart honey's like
[ __ ] hold the [ __ ] on
and scours the website the whole
internet being like
oh found a coupon boom this [ __ ] happens
all the time with ela we're shopping
online buying shoes pants
whatever and then it's like oh honey
just saved you thirty dollars honey to
save you fifty dollars i've saved
hundreds if not thousands of dollars
with honey and when you're shopping on
honey
a box comes out and says apply coupons
just click that and you're done
let me tell you honey has found its 17
million members
over two billion dollars in savings
that's amazing i'm sorry was that a b
yes billion so if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out on free savings it's literally free
installs in a few seconds and by getting
it you're gonna be doing a solid and
supportive of this podcast five dollars
on headphones so
thank you thank you honey that's how i
got paid i love honey i use it all the
time i don't browse without it
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
frenemies
that's jointhoney.com
honey
tesla giveaway time you know amazing
what that we are giving away a tesla
literally just to dunk on david dobrik
that's why i wanted to do this
thanks to with peace and love to amaze
who we you know we love and appreciate
them sponsoring
but i was like if we can give away tesla
then i'll do it because
i'm the new david dobrik now
thanks omaze okay here's uh yeah
great here's what amazes okay
you're helping charity you're donating
and you're simultaneously
being entered to win a mother loving
tesla
s and twenty thousand dollars let's get
it that's amazing
here's the charity you're gonna be
supporting um give power
which i love this one yeah give power
did you know there's roughly 2.2 billion
people around the world do not even have
access to safely manageable drinking
water
i love give power uh they're a
non-profit that uses
solar expertise to clean water they're
desalinating water
and like brutally dry conditions that
sounds like a los
angeles let's get let's get give power
out here in los
angeles uh no i think there's worse
places off than that
this experience uh so hey let's get the
people some water you know what i mean
yeah so it's helping everything there's
another one two was the other one
there's two of them
the other one is called 501c3 and it
seeks to mobilize the next generation to
fight climate change by creating a
global community that embraces low
carbon
culture let's go environmentally it's
awesome
it's a whole environmental package we
got tesla's we got desalination we got
oh my god we're saving
power all of that we are getting
paid to save the planet pretty cool
when you go to omaze.com frenemies you
can get an automatic entry if you donate
ten dollars
okay let's forget about boring ass
charities and talk about the tesla
you're gonna win david dobrik finds
i like the charities as well though just
for the record yeah but who cares
model s was my first nice car uh-huh
love this car it's sporty
it's quiet i'm telling you baby there's
ain't nothing like that
you just describe me fast sporty
yeah quiet i don't think anything they
should call it a tesla model trish
cheshire model trash yeah i like that
i would buy that um and did i mention
twenty thousand dollars i mean come on
guys this is a really cool thing to do
you're gonna be helping the world you'll
be getting possibility to win some [ __ ]
i mean come on
you know what i'm saying so for your
chance to win a custom tesla model s
plus twenty thousand dollars go to omaze
dot com
slash frenemies and enter now one more
time
that's omaze.com friend reason answer
now the best part is every donation
supports the work
of give power and 501c3 can you all work
on that name
501c3 i mean it's a mouthful but okay we
love you anyway
so hurry up and that's omaze.com enemies
go there donate and good luck
all right we're back and today we are
going to talk about keemstars the worst
human being ever
thank you for the animal crackers oh
yeah moses came dropped by a little
feed i did some mean jokes but i thought
it was funny can i do him
yeah he's like here eat some eat some
animal crackers piggy
that's funny i felt it was but it was it
was felt meaner now but
during the break everyone's laughing
it's glare
yeah that's i do well because he's like
here well you said oh he's dropping off
he's feeding me i was like here little
here
piggy i didn't start the feeder
oh [ __ ] intense inhale
here why don't you snort those i don't
know if i can let's do some lines of
animal crackers bro you want to get
[ __ ] up today
yeah are these cedar or snacks am i
eating his snacks i feel bad
he's got it are they his life
well he's got boxes of animals he's not
starving don't worry about him
um he doesn't ever eat i've never seen
eating like my niece and nephews are
always eating they're eating why he eats
a
lot
oh really clearly he's alive he's
growing he's not like
he's not like dying i mean the kid eats
what do you want
thank you all right we can go okay okay
so
on the schedule or no which one i bought
so we're over that what
hype house what i literally
what are you actually serious hi pals
hype house
hi pals i don't understand your words
you swear in your life
you're so dumb i swear to god you were
not saying hi fouls can i just talk
about keemstar
it's been like an hour and i haven't
even got one [ __ ] thing i wanted to
talk about
i don't even keep up with me i have him
blocked and i have one other person
blocked and that's it i never see their
stuff and i live very happy that way
yeah blocking is
is s is godly they say the heirs human
to block is godly
who says that confucius said that
confucius says what kavicha said that
anyway
keemstar is the worst person live if you
don't know anything about him here
because we've been talking a lot about
sexual
assault allegations and i felt like
there
it's a very important thing going on uh
and you know
it's happening way more than any of us
would like to admit especially on
youtube
the problem is you've got people like
keemstar who's a popular channel
a news channel that somehow people take
seriously um and
saying [ __ ] like this publicly about the
jake paul allegation now you guys
remember justine
paradise she came out against jake paul
saying that she was essayed
in the mouth forcefully you guys have
all seen that we talked about it
so here's keemstar's take on that
situation
now uh i guess i should issue a trigger
warning this is very offensive
and horrific hey guys
uh i need to do a dromler today on the
jake paul sexual assault allegations
and quite frankly i do not believe the
alleged flick victim
and i don't want to love that just right
out the gate i don't believe her
but wait till you hear why this is bad
karma already he has bad energy coming
his way to say this about someone like
it's i don't wish it on him but like
this is bad to put out there like that
dude it makes me feel like really
uncomfortable for him
if you want to know anything about dude
just google his name and
it's like this guy's done [ __ ] that
this guy's done [ __ ] that would make uh
david dobrik look like a [ __ ]
like uh the tooth fairy and this is like
current like you you know
like oh 10 years ago he's doing this
currently like in this like climate
yeah this just came out and he has a he
actually has a history of being a rape
apologist which i'll show you guys it's
kind of
wild just cover this real quick on
dramaalert without getting some pushback
maybe there's something i'm missing
maybe
maybe i'm not seeing a certain angle to
the story that's why i'm making this
twitter video so i can be
challenged before i put it on dramaalert
in front of millions of people but
this girl is claiming that jake paul you
know was kissing her holding her hand
led her to her room she didn't want to
do any further stuff with him
and then jake paul like grabbed her head
and started [ __ ] her face
and within 30 seconds busted a nut in
her mouth
and she claims that she was sexually
assaulted now
how does that happen i just i like what
wouldn't she have to open her mouth and
like participate
in some way for that to happen like
can't you just
turn your head or can't you just get
like is
is there is there is there some way to
force
oral sex on someone i mean
she's not saying that he had a weapon
and was like you better do this you know
she is saying
that he grabbed her head and started
[ __ ] her face
and came in her mouth
i don't understand the physics here like
i don't understand how that's possible
like why
like i would can't you get away is there
really no way to get away
is there really no way to just close
your mouth or like it just
not let the penis enter your mouth like
come on like i'm sorry
but i just don't believe this story at
all
am i missing something here please
yeah he's missing a lot she actually had
a really great response to him she said
this is akin to someone saying oh just
close your legs if you're being you know
oh my god
um challenge me please he he is
so i mean yeah he this is a rape apology
right here
101. this reminds me of those what do
they call them like
was it incels like the elliott kid that
shot the school up like that that's the
vibe
i get from him it's just like definitely
not getting [ __ ] by
whoever like definitely is he and his
youtube channel taken away once like you
know you know
it's like not even his channel like he
got banned like five times so how is he
still allowed
even on twitter you know but other
platforms will punish you for things on
twitter like if you document on twitter
like youtube like not youtube
necessarily but like patreon will like
take away like how is he on any
platforms with this
i agree i mean i fully agree i think his
presence is is a danger to everybody
um and and the platform you know but
like him coming out here and saying
that you can't get essayed orally that
she should just turn her head away it's
like
so dangerously ignorant
um and it makes me think when i see
someone like this it just makes me think
like oh he's trying to
he's trying to uh he's talking about
himself for sure
and his friends like like he's got all
these [ __ ] like frat boy friends and
it's like
oh yeah oh and that dude's like oh this
[ __ ] happens all the time
so none like none of us are essayists
it's like well
this is why i get me in trouble what i
feel like because i know you're like you
shouldn't bring his kids into it but
like honestly this person shouldn't have
a daughter like this really makes me
like scared that this is like the
mentality that someone
thinks like this can't happen at all so
like if his daughter ever said something
like this he'd have that same excuse
it's like so
scary that i don't know how these people
can even be like parents having like a
child and like you know i don't know i
know i hate for her could be like
shouldn't talk about kids but like
that's so gross if this is a father of a
girl
because you know why i know so many
girls i had like essays and all that
crazy [ __ ] that happened to them as kids
and it's like the same mentality that
their dad had it was like
well you showed your boobs so like you
should be like asking for it if you got
like groped by a teacher or something
you know what i mean like i think that's
just so
he's so gross no yeah it is sad that he
has a daughter because like
she's not going to get the [ __ ] uh
she's not going to get a good healthy
male role model that's so gross like
it's so embarrassing
and then if this is a troll it's such a
disgusting troll like he's just trying
to get attention
yeah i think maybe he's trying to get
attention to drama or i don't know
whatever it is it's actually like
neither he has a history of saying he
really truly believes this
but i'll say you know he says like oh
jake didn't have it's not like he held a
weapon through her head
it's like dude you're talking about a
girl that probably weighs close to 100
pounds
and jake paul who's been training for a
boxing match he's like six one probably
weighs like two
over 200 pounds he is a weapon she also
said in the video she said multiple
times she said no so even if it
if you do do it just to get it over with
which i've done many times it doesn't
mean that you can send it to whoever
wanted it so make sure you feel less of
a person
she says in the video it was all so
shocking it happened so fast
you didn't even realize what happened
until it was over that's what traumatic
traumatic shocking situations are like
every time your misunders your
unwillingness to actually even empathize
with her a little bit
and then come out and call her a liar
just straight out the gate be like i
don't believe her
i mean it's the same guys who go oh we
should believe all women we should
believe all women
but this [ __ ] is a liar because she
should have turned her head away it's
like whoa dude
and you know a lot of a lot of people
for some
ungod gone god knowing reason actually
look up to keemstar
oh dude i don't know people who shoot up
schools and stuff yeah
i don't know dude no no that's it like i
don't understand like
even jake paul's response was like a
little more like
dignity if you guys don't know anything
about etika you should look into that
because that's one of the most tragic
things that's happened on youtube
history
keemstar this guy was having a manic
breakdown do you know about etika
we talked about it once and i know he
like cut it he was like a really sweet
gamer kid uh growing youtuber
and he was having like a bunch of manic
episodes he was clearly bipolar
and keemstar would bring him on his show
all the time and parade him around
in the midst of a manic state one time
actually
he tweeted out the location of his
mental hospital and then when he got out
of the mental hospital he brought him on
his show in the midst of a mental
breakdown
and he said okay so
keemstar says to him
why he says if you think that life is
all a simulation why don't you just jump
off for bridge
right now of course he he wasn't no
keemstar wasn't saying go jump off a
bridge
but a few months after that
keems or etica jumped off a bridge and
committed suicide
and i'm just saying you look at his
interaction with this dude attica
and his history of using and abusing
people with mental illnesses
and that you should see the tweets he's
made about how mental he's literally
tweeted
mental illnesses are made up just to get
just
for people to get attention like he
doesn't believe melted illnesses are
real
ironically being that he's probably got
the most severe one of any of the people
that
absolutely know on you really wrong with
them
no the guys the guy is a total sick sick
dude
he yeah seriously so here's here's
keemstar dramaalert
um casting as much doubt as possible on
our story so this is like his main
platform that he's broadcasting to
million plus people
delegations have come out against jake
paul this youtuber and tick tocker put
out a story basically saying that in
2019 jake paul s aid her
but before we get to that you know these
allegations allegedly happened in 2019
why are they coming out a week before
jake paul is about to
before we get to that let me cast as
much doubt as possible
and basically call her a liar as close
as i possibly can
i yeah i hate him i think he's the worst
because he like eggs on situations that
he's not even involved with right we
talk about james talk about david and
like they are directly involved he's not
directly involved or anything he just
like eggs people on like
right which is to instigate so
negatively and like this like again
this like 2021 where people are so like
you know on edge and stuff like that
it's like
dangerous he was defending david too
before the article came out he was like
david's innocent
david and all these people are innocent
nothing happened nothing went wrong
um what did he tweet he tweeted
something like oh and he showed a
message of him messaging david he's like
don't let ethan and trisha win
i was like i'm sorry this isn't about
winning or losing yeah
he's just he's so he's such a nasty
instigator like just so like
oh it's just so gross and people who
watches like you said the people who are
like the little
in-cell school shooters watching him
will be like yo this is cool like this
is what we talk about you know that's
why people like grow up like this like
keemstar is because they watch this [ __ ]
yeah he's even me a lot on youtube like
i will never say about any channel
except for this
like you know what i mean i don't think
any other channel should be banned off
youtube except for literally keemstar
like well after you so keemstar after
you falsely
accuse someone being so there's this guy
rs glorian gold he's a six-year-old
streamer minding his own business
keemstar puts out the story saying that
he's a convicted pedophile based on a
photo
he saw a photo in a newspaper a loser is
photo and it looked like the streamer
so there's this this random six-year-old
streamer playing runescape
and he puts out a drum alert saying this
guy's a convicted pedo and
everybody floods the stream telling him
to kill himself and all this [ __ ] and
the guy
was completely innocent so after doing
that after the etiquette thing
after being a rape apologist i don't i
agree i don't
i think keemstar should be deeply he's
like the lowest yeah he really is the
yeah i think so especially the making of
the pedophile thing like
people could go kill that person like
it's not just him killing himself but
people will like try and kill him
oh my god it's just it's horrific you
know and he
he just will openly lie about [ __ ] like
he
he's lied about me saying that like i
stole hundreds of thousands of dollars
and he refused and he will not remove
the video even after i've shown that
like dude that's just you're [ __ ]
straight up lying about you do when
someone literally just makes up lies out
of complete thin air like what do you do
well you can sue them for slander but i
don't want to go down that path
that's my only thing it's also like just
so hard because it's like money loss and
like all that stuff like that
um god i don't even know i i'm just not
up for it i mean
i made a i made a bunch of videos about
the whole situation and i'm fine with
the way
the way it shook out oh but yeah man
he just isn't bad like it's just bad
karma especially because he's like what
he's our age right or a little older
it's like at your thirties yeah
you don't need to like late thirties at
any age but the fact that you're still
instigating such
negativity and it's like strange the
alleged victim says that
by the way it makes total sense that it
will come out now because she's seeing
jake paul everywhere and she had a
really traumatic [ __ ] incident
and this is very common again keemstar
feeling to understand the most basic
principle of
of being a victim when you see your
abuser's face
all over the place and being louded and
being accepted by popular media
it's traumatic and you [ __ ] that's
when it hurts the most well
it ties in but not really like i know
two different things i wouldn't call him
like necessarily his abuser but
in jeff's episode last night he said he
he was cool with david and then he just
started seeing his face everywhere right
and he's like i couldn't like look at
the internet and then he has like shows
like posters of his eyes cut out and so
he's like i couldn't like look at
all these accolades of david without
like having some sort of
like he's like we have to talk because
like you do you see someone
and i feel like me even me too mine is
definitely not severe like jeff's or
even like sex or anything like that but
like you see
these people just keep getting rewarded
and rewarded you're like but this person
like
really damaged me right like you see it
all the time so of course you keep
talking about it because it's so
frustrating you're just like
wow like woody i like anyone you know
it's just like it's just you see them
and of course that's gonna like
yeah that's like rape one again that's
like rape apologies 101 it's like
why now oh you're just chasing clout oh
this it's like dude
or they feel brave enough like a lot of
people came up with david because they
realized like oh
okay maybe we won't get like so much
hate because now like other people have
these stories and i'm going to
corroborate these stories just right
and make a point and that's another
perfect reason is that this is part of a
larger conversation that's playing out
on youtube it's think it's a good time i
think it's a great timing for it
people feel like safer that people
believe victims now and they
they'll look into it and stuff like that
you know also like the new york times i
talked to the new york times author of
this article
and she said they went to great lengths
to
her story they spoke to her friends of
that night who she
talked to crying they spoke to people at
the party who witnessed it
so again it's like keemstar is like this
doesn't seem right
i think she's lying versus the new york
times he's like we vetted this story
we talked to multiple people who were
there at the party to make sure this was
a credible
allegation it's like and then cube
starts like [ __ ] her she's lying cloud
chasing
it's like okay [ __ ] oh god damn dude
i have bad feelings about him too you
know how like i get feelings sometimes
about people i'm like you know
mark jay keemstar well kind of both but
keemstar i feel like
he will push someone some sort of way
and maybe won't be as forgiving as other
people in the past have been and like
he'll get like sued he'll lose
everything he has like something bad's
gonna happen and it's like i don't know
he's pretty much done all the worse
things but if you're
if you're egging people on and
instigating i mean it's it's bad like
that
you well we watched it the little
etiquette part i mean the
the in in his voice you could see like i
hate jesus but like him getting like
triggered and like keemstar like pushing
pushing pushing like not caring
dude and it's like so hard to watch
because clearly that person is like
is is is he's really feeling something
instead of de-escalating he just keeps
pushing and pushing and pushing and
that's like the most like
it's the most interesting you can do to
someone hallmark i mean
yeah i mean dude it's hard it's hard to
overestimate
how damaging this guy has been to people
um
you know it's it's incredible
it's truly is porter and she was told
that wait yeah it just seems a little
strange that they were waiting a week
before jake's fight to put this story
out when it happened like
two years ago he's been working on the
story from myself
references this and his response yeah
and the statement doesn't and there jake
paul actually suggests that she was
doing this to
you know promote her only fans but
anyhow that
is where we're at with this situation
okay shut the [ __ ] up you know this
isn't even the first time
oh she made a response to keemstar which
i thought was pretty good keemstar also
threatened to sue her by the way
um if you don't if you want to know even
more what a people should hear i
understand how that's possible like
why are you kidding me
this man is not just simply saying that
he doesn't believe me
he is saying that it is not possible to
be assaulted orally
yeah are you kidding me not having
consent is not having consent
this logic is like saying well you can't
be raped because you have to open your
legs for that
i have been messaged by so many girls
saying that they went through the same
exact thing of a youtuber
forcing themselves on them but this
person is saying it's not possible
not possible okay is jake forcing you to
say this or do you
genuinely not understand how consent
works i think the latter i think he
generally doesn't understand how consent
work
and by the way she's been like really
brave she's been taking on this whole
story by herself
without really that much support from
the community
and people like keemstar dog piling on
her so i've been really impressed
with her handling of this here's
keemstar threatening to sue her
if you didn't even know what more what
piece of [ __ ] she so he says
jake paul accuser has put out a new
video claiming i said it was impossible
to be assaulted orally this is false
it's like
you kind of [ __ ] did say that
notified my legal team is such [ __ ]
they yeah this is false i never made
such a statement i have notified my
legal team
yeah keemstar keemstar's legal team is
basically like uh
it's like his cousin who didn't who
passed the bar exam 10 years ago but
never practiced legally
he said i forwarded the email to him
doesn't keem claim that he's a lawyer
too i feel like he says he's also a
lawyer or something maybe he is i don't
know
you know what i can have a legal team i
hope he does with someone and whoever
you are i hope he counters to him
because keem always brings
all this money he has and you know what
you can only see somebody with money if
you see someone that doesn't have assets
you're not going to win anything but if
he has money going
he threatened to sue me you never did i
was like sue me you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
oh i get
begging you and he never did of course
you can't what are you doing this girl
for
you what else but also he you did kind
of [ __ ] say that
yeah did you say these exact words
possibly salted orally
no but you did say this just poof your
head close your mouth
it's like really you're going to split
hairs with this and be a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i even know what you actually
said you coward
and said you're going to threaten to sue
her like dude [ __ ] you
such a douche anyway keemstar is the
worst moving on
um you know this isn't the first time
he's actually been a rape apologist
there was this guy jessie smile
or sorry what's this it's a girl that's
the girl
his name was curtis curtis oh you know
the story yeah
so what was the allegation that he
essayed his his girlfriend or something
r word right r worded
so he had a hot take about that of
course which is an another like classic
rape apologists take he says um
i hate cases of artwork most cases only
two people in the world know what
happened
everyone else is guessing the jesse
smiles and curtis story is so hard to
believe because they were boyfriend and
girlfriend oh my god
so he says he keeps someone this dumb
should not be allowed like
on social media or have a family or any
like they shouldn't be allowed to be
socialized like they should be locked
away in an institution like for real
that's like crazy
like the dumbness like the like the
sheer dumbness that's like oh boyfriend
girlfriend like obviously that person
can't
have anything the thought it's like oh
no you can't r word your girlfriend
it's like the thought of that is
actually terrifying that he truly
believes that that
makes me scared for whoever his partner
and his family members are yeah like he
should not be a ladder on it that is
just a dangerous psychotic take like bro
seriously you can't r-word your
girlfriend or i mean what
okay this is the third time kim stars
defended an essayist publicly
so it was so infuriating that eli even
had to do a take on this which i'll read
in a second she tweeted this out
but the situation was that there was a
a female streamer popular twitch
streamer who's in like a content house
with this other dude
and the story is that he got drunk one
night
snuck into her bed into her bedroom got
in bed with her
and started holding her hand and
touching her and [ __ ]
and it made her super uncomfortable
right and so the so
keemstar put out this video basically
you know
being his normal psychotic self he's tr
uh ila said
what a terrible and dangerous tech
victims of sexual assault already have a
hard enough time speaking out when
feelings of shame and guilt
the last thing we need is for someone
like keemstar also criticized how they
should have said no [ __ ] him start
jeez go off queen but here's the video
i'm gonna have a little bit of a rant
and i haven't
researched everything so i don't have
all the details
good way never good by the way how many
i mean let's be honest keemstar what
have you done in your life to make you
so desperate to defend these people
because you're really defending yourself
let's be honest
it's so weird so maybe there's something
extra to this story that i just don't
know about
right okay do your research and then
come back
you're a [ __ ] news man me too
statement
about these gamers they live in a gamer
house one's a guy one's a girl
the guy's drunk he jumps into her bed
he's like
putting his hand up against her chin
first of all
making it sound like all innocent fun
jumping into someone's bed is such a
violation it's so descriptive
yeah in somebody's room and get in their
bed when you're
it's it's just i'm sorry yeah it's not a
fun lighthearted cute thing to do
it's creepy as [ __ ] no he like grabs her
hand
kisses it he might say he grazes his
hand across her chest
and um that's disgusting the fact that
he thinks this is like so normal
you can do that come on who hasn't
gotten drunk and crept into a girl's bed
and grazed the
kids and kissed her fell and smelled her
hair
like you said this is like literally
like projecting like there's something
like oh he's done so he's just like
what's the big deal oh yeah oh
cause i was so shocked by all these
three things that i just didn't even
react i was just i was i just was froze
yeah that makes sense you wake up and
all of a sudden you're being caressed
and growth by some drunk freak
didn't say anything you're scared it's
scary dude it's your responsibility to
say something
if a guy's making the moves on you and
you don't want that to happen you got to
say no
like that that's your responsibility you
have to say
no what it's not girls is not their resp
it's guys responsibilities not to
[ __ ] be
creepy predators you know what i'm
saying oh my god
he yeah that that's basically synonymous
with like
women are asking for it it's like it's
your responsibility to
hold a knife and stab anyone that
approaches you women are asking for it
i don't understand i don't understand
how he's like around like i really don't
understand this like it's so
crazy like i know well i guess what this
is relatively recent too i mean this is
a
this is a that's so scary i think like
if anything like the past year like
people are like okay like this shit's
like not cool like you can't say this
[ __ ] like it's so damn
like the fact that he's like still going
but like even so hard yeah
that's not even like i don't know if i
believe this girl but like saying like
you should have said no that was like
what like that not that all girls it's
all girl's responsibility to say no
i feel like he's gonna like an appealing
one or something this is so scary it's
so scary well some some people think he
already has indirectly
i don't doubt it he said you can't go do
anything
and then be like he wronged me
what you've got to say no you have to
say no
and what are we talking about okay so so
if they said no he's still wronged dude
it's like
he has such a it's so stupid it's like
yeah if you say
no they still wronged you but he also
like really hates women like all this
common theme is like about women like
you should have said no
how does this happen like it's a really
like that's what i'm saying it's like
actually really scary
it's like he has mom deep deep deep
mommy issues for sure
he i don't know i feel like he's gonna
like harm a woman for real because like
these are the people like i watch a lot
of like again serial killer stuff not to
say he is but
this is the same pattern where they hate
women like women don't want to sleep
with them they call them ugly whatever
the case is
and they like hate women for like
because this this person did nothing i
don't even know about the story the
story wasn't even big because i didn't
know about it
so it's like i don't understand no yeah
it's all it's just all
bla every time it's blaming the women
not believing the women
it's it's just it's so much hate towards
women that
i i have to assume he had something
really traumatic happen with his mom and
his childhood
we're talking about kissing a hand
that's what we're talking about
now if you would have said to him get
away from me and he still grabbed your
hand and kissed it fine kissing your
hand
nothing nothing no like hey you crossed
the line
hey too much and he just kisses your
hand
why don't you pull your hand away like i
don't get it
the i mean maybe there's more details
out there that i just don't know about
right so maybe there's more stories out
there about this individual maybe is a
creep
right but based on what i just read and
i didn't even read the full thing
because i couldn't get through it
because i was so angry
that this person is getting me too no
it's like [ __ ] like your girl
you the female have a responsibility to
say no no
stop bro he crept into her bed when she
was sleeping what the [ __ ] do you want
i said he's like girls have a
responsibility to have laser alarms at
the front of their door
so that when guys creep in their bed to
molest them while they're sleeping that
the laser
alarm system will sound the alarm they
go way up immediately and be like no i
do not accept you coming in my room to
grow up me
other than that it's your fault stop
i don't like this get away no you have
that responsibility
he's so upset i don't have all the
details but if this whole man's
career is scary like ruined from kissing
a girl
and it's really scary oh yeah i think
your career should be ruined too
because that's just that's what he's
saying right her career
right that's not right it's not it's not
sexual abuse
it's not rape not abuse it's it's it's
just not right
if he crossed the line you need to tell
him right away you're crossing the line
and
this is some wild hysterical [ __ ] right
i don't know
this is like next level insane no it's
like psychopath for real like
i say that in every sense of the word
and he puts that out there being like
yeah this is a good take
it's gonna be used as evidence in court
one day like i i
just i feel it like it's just so like
something is really really sick
here he is kind of as we've kind of like
been speculating be like hmm i wonder if
he's defending himself in a way
this was actually a really recent video
listen to him talk about this
this whole fedmeister thing just makes
me so he's talking about the same
situation
so the guy's name is fedmeister who's
being accused of being
this creep and so he's talking about
this situation but listen closely to
what he says
it really bothers me you know
when i was in my 20s like i had this
awesome friend group of guys and girls
we all hung out we were all friends we
were all homies
we would party or whatnot and sometimes
people get wasted guys and girls and
they get too touchy-feely
with their friends all right sometimes
things were said that were just like
uncalled for too far but there was
always this like
he's wasted or she's wasted right
we need to take care of our friend they
are wasted
it was never like oh he put his arm
around me when he was wasted
i'm gonna go get he went in her bedroom
dude he keeps trying to
like minimize it the more and more he
thought about it yeah he started
off being like yeah he got in her bed
and he groped her breast to be like oh
he just kissed her hand
oh my friends just put their arm around
each other that's not a big deal
yeah i'm fired from his job that's
insanity
but that's exactly what happened with
offline tv
there uh fed meister got wasted one
night jumped in
one of his friends beds and again they
were in each other's rooms
hanging out all the time but he jumped
in bed with one of them
and he kissed the girl's hand all right
and she didn't say
get off me she didn't say stop she
didn't say this is making me feel
uncomfortable
in fact she said absolutely nothing for
months
until there was a me too movement and
then she came out and put a statement
the the first time she said anything was
to millions of people
which resulted in getting her friend's
entire life destroyed his career gone
for kissing her hand oh my god that
doesn't sit right with me and her
that's supposed to be your friend you
know oh my god
it does clearly again he's not only he's
not only victim blaming it's almost like
it's almost like it's so more than that
it's like she's the criminal
yeah he's stuck in like like two decades
ago where it's like everyone was like
it's changed so much he's like well
people just like protected their friends
it's like
this isn't that's not the era we're
living in like it's so and the fact that
he's filming this and putting us out
there
but i think it's interesting i was like
we used to have this friend group when
we're in our 20s and we would always go
over the line
yeah i was like oh really and look at
keem now yeah
i wonder why i wonder what happened kim
i wonder if you
are the one that went over the line
maybe yeah yeah
insane it's insane that he would even
admit this stuff it's so weird it's so
crazy
i'm so like so that's it i wanted to do
a little keemstar 101 for people who
aren't
aware of actually what a horrible i
think it's good to put it out there i
mean
again i'm not trying to be like this
like overdramatic person but at least
there's like evidence out there that he
hates women if something happens to any
woman around him or in his life or
something there's like evidence that
there's like he
or me or anybody he's just really really
hateful and like nasty
and almost scary it's like borderline
scary because he's just so angry
at something has nothing to do with him
like it's just really
well if you guys want more information
on keemstar i made a whole three-part
documentary about him
on my on my old channel which is kind of
a dead meme at this point but
it's here i did three parts he's the
worst person ever
content new keemstar what
that means yeah it's a dead meme that
old channel
people aren't going to be happy to hear
that but is it true i probably
that's a meme i'm not sure what that one
is
you don't know that meme is that like
the drake one where it's like ah
and then it's like uh oh my god it's a
popular meme i have your most popular
meme
you're doing the girl who's like the
girl who's like huh yeah okay
i don't think that's the most popular i
typed in most popular meme and it was
i wanted a five hundred thousand dollar
car and was like it's five hundred
thousand dollars so i signed the meme
that was like
you're like that's nothing to me i said
you're like i scored
dude i get paid five hundred thousand
dollars just squirt in our own bed i
don't think we've gotten one episode
you mentioned squirting and it's not in
the bed it's in the fountain you scored
it in the fountain
yeah really you just added extra liquid
yeah that's gross because theory i know
i thought about that i don't want to go
there
you don't love playing in that phone
okay but it does recycle it
you got to empty your pool now okay
let's keep it moving
you can't squirt in the phone i know it
recycles it like it gets new water in
there there's no water that goes in
there
it was a lot it was it was it was after
if you think about it long enough
okay trisha's squirting goes to the
ocean it's evaporates
if you think about it in the most like
abstract way it is
raining tricia squirt on us as it rains
you're welcome
that's a lot am that's my new favorite
meme
and anyway and then we've got jeff
widdick um
which i paid for his patreon last night
because he's like oh i'm not gonna put
this on youtube anymore and then you
sent me the link to he put it on youtube
i was like wait i just speak ten dollars
for this
yeah he put it on youtube later i was
happy that he wasn't gonna do it and
then he did it well he said he was gonna
censor it
and it's like i don't i don't really i
mean i don't i'm not really
dying to see your bloodied [ __ ] up eye
it's it's a lot
it's kind of too much like i saw the
uncensored versions like
i kind of like the censored version
better uh everyone's very casual about
it i applaud like jeff for like
trying to make something good out of
that situation and like trying to make
something like productive and creative
it's like why is everyone soaked why is
like david and natalie just being
interviewed like
as if nothing happened right i agree
it's by the way
weird vibe i don't get that i don't get
the angle of it again i love jeff no
hater jeff and jeff is 100 a victim in
this 100 but like i don't get the angle
like
he's trying to give like david like this
redeeming quality like david you know
what i mean or is it like
what's he i don't know it's such a weird
it's such a hard thing to grasp i don't
know it's such weird when i'm watching
well first let me say
that i had mentioned that jeff was gonna
be calling in today
jeff was we had talked about him calling
in today but he had some surgery on his
face
and he's not feeling well yet to me on
camera so jeff will not be calling in
today i just want to let you guys know
that
people who are expecting that so did you
say that
i had said on friday i think that he
might be calling in today because uh
we were gonna see but let me let me show
the um
the sequence of events for people that
are unfamiliar so david
just like you said that everyone's
calling you a liar
they took a [ __ ] excavator out into
the some lake bed
and david was operating the excavator he
doesn't have a license to operate the
excavator
i don't know who owns that excavator but
they're they should be liable too for
all this because jeff
literally almost died and i think they
would all go to j they would be in jail
for manslaughter and whoever's
owns that excavator would also be going
to jail pretty sure
but at any rate um i mean thank god he
didn't die
oh thank you oh yeah david would be in
jail
he would be in [ __ ] jail but you know
what i think like last time was like
it's weird that like david
to me i would have like this endless
guilt that i like messed up this guy's
like like you know like at least his
face and stuff for a while and
it took a year of his life basically
because he couldn't do [ __ ] and it's
like he doesn't have like any guilt he
just went on to go
do his own thing like building a podcast
studio buying new homes like
just and it what from what jeff said he
didn't from the impulsive episode he
didn't talk for
him for like six or seven months so it's
like how are you just going on living
your life
when i would feel it i feel guilt for
dave i feel bad for david for feeling
guilt but i guess he doesn't feel guilt
about it which is so weird
no and apparently they're still friends
which is good i guess if it's good if he
forgives them you know but damn like i
think jeff is just trying to be
i don't i think jeff is just trying his
best to like
heal and recover and not hold resentment
but you can tell i'll show clips from
the documentary which i think
a few good ones obviously i recommend go
watching it on his channel jeff woodwick
but
um that really i feel show reveal
he's tip going around his real feelings
and you can tell he
he there's deep down what he's unwilling
to see on camera
is that he is deeply resentful of david
and this whole situation
as well he should be i don't think he
yeah but anyway a year of his life is
gone i mean it's a life-changing uh for
sure it's
it's a life-changing injury i mean it's
not even a year of his life gone it's
way worse he hasn't been able to do
anything he couldn't do like his
barbershop episode you know i mean like
so really the stuff he was like going
for it like going towards he just
couldn't do anything is david's paying
for his medical bills but he owes him so
much more than that
yeah the guy is unable to [ __ ] work
and again this is the [ __ ] that they
hear
they're not employees of david but they
dan they sing and dance on david's
command and then when he gets a
life-changing injury do you think he
gets workers comp or any kind of benefit
like that no because they don't have
that set up
robbery exactly exactly because any
other set like they would have like
insurance for that like you know
exactly but you know what did you see do
you have the zane clip
of zayn and he's talking about how they
just threw jeff's injury into todd and
um
he's being injured too todd and he like
both wrecked their shoulder on this trip
and they also just threw like jeff into
and like oh and jeff and they like
laughed about it it was on zayn and he's
podcast like it's insane
that they like this made it like it was
literally like weeks after it happened
yeah a bunch of us it was it's out there
i mean i'm sure it's something out there
and it was i think
you know deaf noodles and definitely
noodles um
but no like zayn literally was just like
they were just laughing they're like
dude like everyone got injured like you
todd you're talking about heath todd and
and then they threw jeff in there like
he's so badly concerned
like laughing after after this and
seeing his eye like that's insane to
even like talk about on that
cracked his [ __ ] skull open he
cracked his whole
[ __ ] skull could you imagine even
being there and seeing it that alone
would traumatize me for like a reason
i'm saying the whole vlog squad how they
all just didn't talk about this and act
like it didn't happen is insane
if you were there i would like to think
that i would be supporting
jeff and that like you i think there
should be a collective
movement to be like yo this thing went
way too [ __ ] far we need to support
jeff who almost died for this stupid
[ __ ] vlog
the tone is just so awesome it should be
more serious like i just don't
understand how this tone is so like
whatever this idiot was driving this
excavator like no his i i just
i think his tone is serious but he's
trying his best to
i think jeff is afraid of david's fans
and he's trying his best to toe a line
you know what i didn't want to put that
on him he's trying to tow a line between
being like yes this was [ __ ] up
and but also being like it was an
accident and
i don't you know but even like the tone
of like like watching him come and dress
with the joker even though it's just
that jeff was his idea
it's just like it's such a bad way to
set it it's like oh your friend will
just forgive you if you like almost like
kill them you know what i mean
let's watch that's why i have all the
clips set up let's watch them but here
here's the video you were talking about
uh david dobrik may have allegedly
injured more vlog squad members than
jeff
on the excavator stunt heath uh
complained days later his shoulder was
broken
what he was hanging on to a floaty and
the excavator was like
whipping him around and he like went off
of it so yeah
he [ __ ] broke someone else's shoulder
on that trip and he had a cast on for a
long time on that because i watch his
pocket oh my god
it's crazy because i feel like it didn't
really hit you until
days later yeah it's been very delayed
tell us all about it how'd you how did
you break it well i don't want to get
into the specifics um i'm sure you guys
will see why
why what is with these people i don't
know david almost killed me he broke my
arm but i don't want to say anything
about daddy david
very soon we've been doing [ __ ] for the
past couple days but we can't like speak
on it at all
but you'll find out probably by the next
podcast but we just
dude are you guys really telling me that
a four minute vlog is this [ __ ]
important to you all and then after all
this they're like you'll probably find
out the next podcast i mean they thought
david was going to release this
footage and you guys oh you'll know then
it's like why because david probably
like was like
someone's like you know if you put this
out
you you could go to jail i don't think
there's one person with common sense
around him i don't think anybody said
that to him i think he just maybe
maybe he had a maybe a lawyer or
something i don't know they're like did
you have a license operate that he's
like no he's like
you broke the law and almost killed
someone in doing it
yeah because we're not sure what's gonna
happen yet isn't that like the
definition of second-degree murder
as you get someone killed while breaking
the law
uh it varies from state to state okay
thank you legal expert dan
is it really yeah we just don't know
what's gonna happen yet so we have to
wait but i did something to it
and when it happened i was like oh that
hurt really bad
and i think it was just my adrenaline
just kind of in the moment i was excited
and uh it felt fine and now two three
days later
um i can't move it like
at all and what sucks about the
situation is that when when it happened
to heath
he didn't feel it for like a day and a
half and then him and scott went
dirt bike riding the next day
jeff who's in the hospital right now
getting his face reconstructed like this
is
right after it happened so they why do
they not care why do they not care about
their friend jeff they're such fake
friends
i'm sorry i'm [ __ ] jeff has told me
that for sure he calls him fake
i don't know like i could think publicly
he said i think he's scared of david's
fans but like he's told me like
i'm sorry about that [ __ ] phony
[ __ ] dude it pisses me off anyway so
here's the situation
they did the wake boarding and all this
so i don't even know what they're trying
to do but they set up a rope swing
on the excavator arm karina goes up
first
it's way insane for her she gets freaked
out and makes david stop and she says
to him you take it too far karina gets
on it and then david starts
moving it's like the shot looks so sick
this looks beautiful
okay it's not worth it
the thing comes off and it starts
falling down and corona is like
what the [ __ ] put me down put me down
[Music]
david it was clearly extremely dangerous
the water's one foot
one foot of water so it's like you're
just falling into water you're like
gonna like break something
exactly so it's clearly very dangerous
and she's angry so he's like okay jeff
you're next
[Music]
oh my god oh my god laughs
it's crazy it's not funny it's not it's
not actually funny
she's she's upset it's not actually
funny dude that's the thing
she was just interviewed by the
hollywood fix and he's like are you
gonna be back in amazon she says yeah
when he starts vlogging
like everyone's just like okay whatever
girl just do your thing have a plane
20 times what's the worst that could
happen if i swing from a rope
over a one foot deep lake and yeah i
didn't know i was gonna go that fast
so i grabbed the [ __ ] rope and i
tried to make a goddamn funny video for
people
but this is where i made a mistake
this this is one of the moments where
he's kind of does dish it to david and
suddenly the biggest [ __ ] idiot i
know was driving it
he said he made one mistake the biggest
[ __ ] idiot he knows was driving it
now this is really important okay before
we get to the actual accident here
i can show it don't show it well no it's
it's from a farm goddamn
funny video for people but one thing
worth showing here is that dave oh
let me grab this made a mistake i forgot
that the biggest [ __ ] idiot i know
was driving it
you can see david i mean there's better
shots of it but david is operating with
one hand
and holding the camera in his other hand
so not only is he not licensed to be
driving this escalator he's operating
and it's specifically dangerously
it's so so i just don't understand
when people are like trisha predicted
this it's like this has happened so many
times you didn't even predict it you
don't have a psychic to tell you like
this like this will happen again like
he's done he's injured so many people
and it's like how how how could you not
enter someone like it's so great they're
so
dumb like they're so unbelievably stupid
that it's like actually i have no
empathy or sympathy i hope he feels
guilt but he obviously doesn't feel
guilt either which is what's crazy to me
it's like
he's done this so many times to people
and people just like let it slide
because they're looking like they they
think they owe david something like a
career i don't know what it is
but it's i'm i'm so perplexing i don't
know what it is either
i just afraid of the mob of david's
they're calling him david's boyfriends i
think someone called them
those people like that i don't know if
it's funny i don't know but like this
david stands i think they're afraid of
the david stands
daddy david i don't think there's
anything any left more of david stan so
i don't think you gotta be worried i
think they're very
few and far between star
you should be afraid of him he's an
actual psychopath maybe be afraid of
that guy
so here it is he's spinning him around
you know
the funny thing is like in normal life
situations after what happened to cringy
be like oh this is unsafe we shouldn't
do it again consider yourself lucky she
didn't get hurt yeah but he's like no
we're gonna step it up so he spins jeff
around super fast oh oh
his head slams into the crane and uh you
know his head he goes into the water
why didn't he stop or do you know what i
mean like how did why did he break he
doesn't
know how to operate an excavator i've
heard a lot of speculation
uh from people that that know about
these machines and apparently it's a
it's a built-in safety thing when it's
spinning that fast it automatically
stops because it's not supposed to go
and the thing is is if he was trained on
that piece of equipment he would know
that that could have happened
and so it's unlikely that he
intentionally stopped he was probably
just holding the controller going
yeah and then it just stopped suddenly
because he's going too fast i guess that
was my
question like how did it happen but yeah
but the the it all comes down to he's
not qualified he doesn't know what he's
doing yeah
and it's and activators are not toys for
a reason they're extremely [ __ ]
dangerous machines
and this was just for our vlog that's
what we found out was he was doing a
vlog yeah just a vlog
okay so that was episode two which
neither of us talked about then episode
three came out
yesterday i think or the day before and
um yesterday so
here's some of the information and some
of the aftermath of his injury
some interesting parts
here i feel like nobody had an answer of
what was going to happen and all i kept
saying is
god please just watch over him and make
sure that he's okay
when i woke up in the hospital i was in
shock i was in a lot of pain
i tore some ligaments in my leg i broke
my foot i broke my hip i shattered my
skull in nine
places i shattered my eye socket i
almost lost my eye
and i almost died the only thing you
want to do when you wake up in pain is
just heal
i'm not an expert but i think i hit the
tractor holy [ __ ] jeff
i thought you were dead i was dead too
you're joking
right when we got here they asked you
what your job was and you said you're a
male model
how's that a joke bro we got a dream in
botox
you're not freaking out right so anyway
i just wanted to show
the the private the gr the amount of
injuries he had you know he listed
he had a torn ligament he broke his foot
he [ __ ] broke his hip shattered his
skull i mean that's insane
yeah uh there's a few choice
places here in the documenting but if
you want to watch the whole thing
obviously go to his channel jeffwiddick
but this was not my fault i didn't sign
up to swing around an excavator at 60
miles per hour
david he didn't sign up to nearly kill
his friend and nearly lose everything
that he's worked for nobody asked for
this but this is what happened
i know that i'll come back from this and
i'll make it on my own
but we're lucky that i'm not dead and
i'm not blind it was just
a lot emotionally i felt scared and
angry
that i had to go through this i want to
erase that day and get back to where i
was at
[Music]
that's really good i mean that's just
cool
i guess i mean that was my that's just
my only issue i would say is there's no
disclaimer to be because you know they
said nobody asked for this which of
course they didn't but they should
disclaim like
you shouldn't do these like unsupervised
like you shouldn't do this without like
i
didn't like that they didn't he didn't
talk about that like no responsibility
of course but like disclaimer don't do
this unsupervised without strong
coordinators without the licensing with
all that stuff like that like
that's a really good point there's no
responsibility
yeah that's what i'm talking about like
the tone of it it's like of course david
didn't want to kill you of course you
don't want to get hurt
but you all did something that like
disclaimer don't do
like if there's no coordinator if you
have training in it like no insurance
yeah no
no properly trained driver criminal
negligence
right exactly criminal negligence people
don't so much negligence in this and
like everything else like david has done
like that that's what it is it's like
how's your responsibility i think you're
right he's giving him too much of a pass
here
but it's not his i think david needs to
own this
i mean like again david needs to [ __ ]
like the guys
the guy almost killed his friend through
criminal negligence
and skated by for years
without [ __ ] acknowledging it yeah
he's like i'm just a joker
everything's fine none of these goons
ignore the highlight for
you know what will make this better if
you come skydiving with me i'm like
that's what's going to make this better
like that's
what i don't blame jeff though because
he's like just trying to be a good sport
you know what i mean
i'm not blaming jeff i'm saying there
needs to be a disclaimer for people
watching like
someone is at fault like somewhat you
did you know what i mean there is
something wrong with this situation it
wasn't just an a freak accident we
didn't ask for this it's like
it wasn't like a [ __ ] rock came
falling out of the sky and hit jeff in
the head it wasn't an act of god
it was an act of criminal negligence
right good point
here's the doctor telling jeff how close
he was to dying that angle of what you
hit would have been about three degrees
different
or if that would have entered about
three millimeters higher and been on the
same angle it would cut your eye right
now
and if it was a few inches the other way
would have killed me i wouldn't
go in the other way you would have
caught the big blondes now so you would
have died yeah
oh that was going so fast yeah you could
have died so easy
that is insane i believe that this life
is not random
i think yeah there's a doctor being like
dude you that was insane you could have
died
so easy um
crazy it's interesting he's getting
views on it and it's interesting and i'm
glad he can get
that out of this you know there's like a
story like that's good for him i like
he's making the best of it and that's
good that's what he needs to do
i think part of his like redemption arc
or like just his comeback even is just
he's trying to do it in a way that
doesn't bring other people down and i
respect that
here he is kind of getting real about
his feelings towards david oh
most people start their day they look at
their phone and the first instagram
story would be him
and i would click on it and it would be
him being praised for something that he
accomplished that week and i'm sitting
here in my house
in the worst place i've ever been
thinking i'm never gonna get back to
where i was at
it made me resent him and maybe
represent cena's face and maybe not want
to go online
maybe not want to open up youtube it
would just put me in a bad place
like i'm healed enough to walk around
but i'm still really [ __ ] up
so you guys both have to sit down and
talk about it david space is so
triggering to me i can't imagine being
deaf like david space is so
triggering and especially those guys at
the best part in particular i was like
this is exactly it like i was friends
with david for a year and a half right
like
go to his hometown for the holidays like
everything and it's like the minute i
went to the hospital overdose and all of
a sudden i'm in mental hospital so i'm
crazy
i never heard never once was a text are
you okay he came to see me in the
hospital see your side i never once was
like
are you okay a couple weeks later are
you fine i get that one even my friend
but like literally
not only that but cutting me off and not
only that but like talking [ __ ] about me
within the group like all these people
have told me stuff after and it's just
like that's
crazy that they still try to pinpoint me
as crazy and it's like it's so
triggering like so trauma someone you
think is your like friend this is like a
different of course different but
i can't look at david's face the same
thing to jeff
jeff got injured and he just kind of
dropped him and you know
he it seems like jeff was kind of
david's like skeleton in his closet and
he wanted to keep him there
and that's why nobody [ __ ] talked
about it he didn't know what to do
to be there for you he almost died jonah
all you had to do was come check on me
talk to me man a man in person and
that's it i can lie
and say everything's fine yeah but
that's not going to get me anywhere
i wanted to make it clear to him that
this was a problem that
we both had to fix now
hey guys i made a move so anyway um
just kind of where it leaves off and i
think the
next part is leaving this leading as
some kind of like reconciliation between
the two of them so
i don't know but regardless of what
happens in part four
you know i mean this is criminal
negligence bro and i know
i know that jeff's trying to be the big
man about it but
i don't have to be the bigger man about
it or at least just tell people like hey
we were not doing something right and
this is why this is the result of that
dude that's such a good point i really
do think that's so important to
acknowledge
really yeah
um you know and david first of all this
is not the first time david has
seriously injured someone in their vlogs
this i know this is like a random fluke
but like okay apparently
david [ __ ] caused his childhood
friend to like get amputated
and like what are the chances that
you've done this to someone twice like
even by accident
sorry about how i ruined my best
friend's life this is alex knew alex if
you guys don't know
he was a big sports player in school he
played basketball football baseball like
look he looks like an athletic guy right
michigan uh no g for great sports
we were in the seventh grade we were
having a pine cone fight out like in the
backyard area
long story short i threw pinecone right
in his eye it got infected and soon he
started to get like flu-like symptoms so
he had to go to the doctor i was in the
hospital for like
a week and a half cost us about ten
grand out of pocket ten thousand dollars
for a pinecone
and the doctor ended up telling him that
he got a staph infection and this staph
infection
it ended up eating bone marrow in his
hip
so not only does he now need a hip
replacement but he needs
extra bones and weird procedures just so
he can walk straight again
they told me like when they got these
he's using it for content too he's like
this is how i ruined my best friend's
life clickbait uh
20 ads uh my best friend stuck with the
ten thousand dollar bill
it can't play sports i know it's like
this one seems like it's all action but
like what's the chance you ruined your
friend's life twice
multiple times back to 100 in like six
months
and how long has it been uh six years
fast forward a couple months he's on
crutches and he remained on crutches for
four
years when they told him that this would
all be resolved considering i'm sure i
would want to put this out there if i
was david i don't know
it's like i'm embarrassed i'm humiliated
right i just want to help you i'm not
here to laugh at you the fact that i
ruined yours
goes to a good college where do you go
community college goes to community
college and he's getting good grades why
are you [ __ ] on him for going to
community college
last semester c c which is good
because that c stands for can't get any
better that's what it stands for
i feel really bad for doing that for
alex so right now right here
in front of everyone i wanted to give
him a quick shout out make sure you guys
go follow him on twitter
could you imagine i'm cured okay
this is my favorite part about this
entire that's it a little fodder for the
vlog
i hate it just oh he triggers me so much
sorry i just got
really upset jonah also apparently ended
up in the hospital and almost died
we are i'm we have a half hour long so i
mean is this good or not i thought it
was interesting
it is it is but i really wanted to do
trivia so anyway i'll just say you know
he almost killed his friend jonah who
went to the hospital after trying to
ride up motorcycles [ __ ] zane split
his head open and had to go to the
hospital
um he broke zane seems like a [ __ ]
mess i don't know anything about that
guy but he
seems like a man here's some memes that
i want to review i'm going light seeing
speed
real fast here's david filming his
friend being attacked by a tiger
being mauled by to death by a tiger
that's a meme you like that yeah okay
good
here's uh david dobrik in the hospital
after almost killing jeff
oh my god this is my this is a meme
treasure they're bio though why are they
not
oh my meme's gonna be are they talks
this kid went to
his grandpa was dying in the hospital
and this kid did a tick tock you know
and
i was just [ __ ] amazing so this is
david uh in the hospital as jeff's
almost
[Music]
is dying real well yeah oh yeah it's
real this is like a classic
uh an iconic one his grandpa
actually i think he may actually be a
dead
i think i don't think i was ever this
dumb at anything
i really don't feel that this is famous
this is a famous okay
for being like so bad music yeah this is
like this is why they changed the name
they went to witness protection after
that they're like oh so that's that's
david uh
as jeff lay david oh my god why is he so
triggering like i feel like i'm getting
like
hives i feel like i'm gonna itch when
you arrive at the party but it's just
david and his camera crew there
get me out now i'm not doing this here
stop yo yo we going to excuse
that's funny because that's actually
happened to so many people it sounds
like
um i've got more memes i'm almost done
we're getting close these are good these
are good people aren't joining they're
not good
david dobrik watching his friends
getting torn to shreds really bobby
brown for some reason with two cameras
david dobrik at the hospital and jeff
wakes up spongebob meme
i mean you could literally just go to
reddit and read all this like why don't
we just redirect people are gonna read
it
no i curated them david dobrik filming
his friends getting injured for content
a nuclear bomb
dan is loving it oh and then finally
one more don't panic i've seen this all
over tick tock and it is interesting
he's look at how he looks already
panicking bro
watch out
[Music]
look at his laugh just focus on his face
oh my gosh
that's so triggering now look at this
meme
excuse me oh my god look at him oh my
god oh my god
what i what is so funny david i don't
know
it's fully joker you really laugh like
what is that about though i don't know
you spend time with him does he really
laugh no he's like so serious in real
life like he's such a little like
he doesn't walk around like at
everything no he like ignores you if he
has nothing to do with david he'll just
like won't even talk to you he's kind of
the worst
where's the joker ones i don't have any
images of that where because
david dressed up like the joker to take
that whatever okay let's play trivia
yeah
okay we don't have much time let's go
let's go all right trivia bring the
boards
actually let's pause we'll cut it
because we got to bring the boards i
don't want to waste any time
okay all right we're just going to cut
okay we're set up for trivia
enemies trivia commence come on
foot soldiers tanks okay we gotta get
through the trip we have three minutes
you're the one that did this whole like
commence thing wait i just looked at us
in the viewfinder you know she cosplayed
x
jessica rabbit and roger rabbit that'd
be fun i'm into that that's how i feel
right now can i be jessica rabbit
that'd be more fun i do want to be able
to be a the male sometimes but maybe
yeah
i want to be in the book that's a rabbit
i literally look like her dude you want
to talk about crushes i wanted to [ __ ]
jessica
should we do it should we do a jessica
rabbit competition so who looks more
like her
we both get glam because that'd be fun
yeah who wants to be roger rabbit boring
i want to be the big boy
rabbit i'll bring with me i have a
little bunny that comes with my costume
i love it you shouldn't be uh maybe you
shouldn't be roger you should be the
the protagonist what's his name eddie
the villain no the
the cop i've never seen the movie okay
we're talking too much about robert
you've never seen roger i just wanted to
[ __ ] the redhead i mean what do you want
from me
at the card too i was like seven years
old you seen those titties
those titties were everywhere i was like
oh [ __ ] okay
okay so we're doing the trivia but we
don't have that much time so what we're
gonna do is we're just gonna have fun
with the trivia but still keeping score
we're gonna keep score and then we're
getting carried over
to next week we're gonna start with
trivia next week so we definitely don't
run there should be a winner
this time there needs to be a winner
right we're not completing the game
what are we in jumanji i don't know what
that means
i know what jumanji is but i don't know
what the reference is or you go home
okay yes we're in jumaji yes we're in
jumanji we're going to complete the game
tomorrow
okay start okay so we're a little less
formalized than the first time we played
uh but we do have
some different categories so i'll just
skip around so um just name the category
yeah i'll hit you with uh let's start
with the science question why don't we
you're both
you're both scientists you know that's
my [ __ ]
okay scientists over there didn't know i
was sitting next to
newton john famous newton john one of
the new ones i don't know i mean isaac
newton
is it i don't know newton john figg
newton
are you making olivia newton-johnson
yeah okay i got you
that's what i was going oh so you're
deep cut okay my favorite sciences
is fig are we are we going
no i'm way again i'm sitting here
waiting for dan to read the [ __ ]
all right here we go what do i gotta do
what egg what is the largest
animal on earth
largest animal on earth the largest
animal on earth
i'll give you something even further the
largest animal to have ever existed
ready yes go ahead three two one
uh it is a blue whale would you put
anaconda anaconda
i thought they were the biggest biggest
snake
yeah probably are you just going off of
the uh jennifer lopez maybe
i was gonna say t-rex but they're no
longer around so i went with anaconda
blue whale is interestingly the biggest
not only the biggest living the biggest
that ever live right
that's literally what dan just said
before right but isn't that interesting
apparently not that interesting because
i [ __ ] know that
i think it's very interesting unlike you
anaconda
okay so i don't know everything about
whales
next all right we'll uh we'll round it
out with another little uh
how about with a history question i
think we're doing oh my god okay
we'll get there sure we'll do history
just do history just history
i'm bopping around bob around all right
what was the first animal
to be sent to space hmm
you know it yeah what is it monkey
monkey you're both wrong
dog it was a dog [ __ ] my tits oh my god
i was like was it a dog or a monkey [ __ ]
in my [ __ ] i just think of that movie
with harlan williams rocket man
and the monkey going with him it was a
dog that's all i think about
i don't know why the poor dog gets sent
first uh
it was the russians so ethan really has
one i'm keeping score too because we can
never
exactly well is it is a dog or a monkey
worse uh
uh a dog is worse hello i have two dogs
they're precious angels monkeys go just
some snippy
chimps are our closest relatives yeah
we'll [ __ ] them dogs i don't even like
my cousins in real life so why would i
like
chimps okay next one i said i don't even
like my living
direct cousins why should i care about
my biological like my
my evolutionary cousins like chimps
that's a joke okay ready i want to win
just let us do
you're gonna run the clock out all right
so we did we did
two uh two of the more traditional
categories we'll move on to a pop
culture
i don't like like a prelude just read
the [ __ ] question
jesus damn i mean we don't have the same
time i don't need like a [ __ ] hole
don't die i'm sorry all right i just
don't have that much time
okay sasha baron cohen portrayed three
characters on his television show that
were eventually made into movies what
were those three characters
i'm sorry dan yeah i would too you're so
triggering
because you
oh my god sasha baron cohen portrayed
three characters on his television show
that would eventually be made into
movies
what were those three characters or
movies
um jewish
he's israeli actually he's part israeli
what speaks hebrew fun fact the language
he's been in borah is actually hebrew
the other guy's speaking armenian but
he's speaking hebrew so they're just
going back and forth in different
languages to each other
wait hold on hold on hold on what's the
third one oh my god
ollie g made three movies about three
different characters
are well okay sasha baron cohen made
three different movies about three
different characters
yep that were all created on his
television show originally
oh my god what's the third one
i think i'm gonna win am i either you
know you don't okay i'm just guessing
all right ready three two one we got uh
bora alley g and bruno that's correct oh
wow
yeah you both got it so wait he made a
bruno movie yeah
yeah oh you remember he had that baby
named oj oh
wait was the bruno movie good i never
said no it's not as good as boring can i
be
still pretty funny can i be honest the
ali g movie [ __ ]
sucks i didn't know that was a movie i
just remembered you show and i was like
i love the leg show but the movie was
just it had some funny moments but it
was scripted that's what threw me off
right i was like i saw bruno with my dad
when i was 13 and it was just his penis
flopping in the camera for like two
minutes straight
and i was like oh man it was drama
yeah the bruno movie's pretty uh pretty
racy all right um
here we go adam sandler starred in seven
movies in the 1990s starred
wasn't just in but like he was like one
of the lead people in it
can you name let's say five of them five
out of just name it yeah if you can name
all seven go for listen
just so you guys know we added a
category called
adam sandler so trisha wouldn't complain
that it's rigged
god if what if i didn't get this i'd be
so embarrassed i mean bro i
i okay let me think here jesus christ
um
seven you said dan yeah i
was surprised when i looked it up he's
busy it's hard because there's like
something that going to 2000 so i'm like
oh which one okay
yep
how many you got actually only four
right now
jesus christ that many films
he was actually in more than seven in
the 90s but uh you know with side
characters and stuff but there were
seven that he
started we have to do the starring ones
not just the ones he did in the night
are these all comedies like
uh they were all comedy yeah okay [ __ ]
me in the tits i really don't know
anything
oh oh
bro i'm sorry i i give up i give up i'm
at six i basically have a happy gilmore
water boy and little nicky uh i feel
like those were later
uh little nikki was in 2000 so that
didn't quite
water boy counter water boy yeah okay i
crossed that out
i had billy madison happy gilmore big
daddy mr deeds and water boy
mr deeds no that that that one didn't
come out
yes he did he was one of the three main
characters i mean how's that starring
it's not just duncan yeah it's like he's
a title yeah
he was one of like three leaders he's
one of three leads okay well anyway you
can
see
me right so that's not fair though you
you crushed me what do you want
adam sandler if you're watching can i be
and don't mess with the zohan too and
who we talk
he's like this [ __ ] is a fake fan she
didn't even get all of them right
she didn't even write airheads wait
really yeah he's like ooh
fake fan alert i have a phone case that
i made
that's my iphone case it's handmade too
so it looks like [ __ ] but
i love you you made that by hand oh yeah
oh i didn't make this my hand but i had
a handmade on etsy by somebody
they just printed it out they screwed me
i paid like 50 bucks for this and they
just printed out pictures and put it on
a phone case so sorry that's a good
business
it's bad it's high risk but it's all
just 2001 uncut jeff there's a whole
industry do you understand there's a
whole industry of people just scamming
you with adam sandler [ __ ] like it's an
industry where there's just one client
and they just send it i know that's why
i had to switch to jack black i had to
go because i can't collect anywhere out
of that
it's not fetish what the hell
kind of so did i win did i get points
yes you won wow so we're tied right
okay thank you all right next up uh
animals that eat both plants and other
animals are called
what
ethan finished pretty fast there i did
all right reveal
omnivore omnivore uh some
interesting spelling choices there but
yeah that's correct we both smell it the
same way
oh that's right i wrote omni i used to
say it
you got it i mean no who spelled it
right anyone
i think ethan got it right oh you
spelled it right i did omn
okay i got the answer right you gotta
really humiliate me on top of that
anymore i am so much fun we both got it
yes we both got a point i am at so much
fun wait did i get two or only one so
far i've only gotten one
we're tied it's three three okay
all right yeah oh okay what is the
you guys ready yeah what is the smallest
country
in the world
the smallest country you know it
yeah why do you know it
i watch it in a movie the smallest
country in the world i feel like i
should know this more immediate
the smallest country in the world
if i'm wrong then the movie lied to me
but i'm pretty sure i'm right
the smallest country in the world boy
country
i'm just taking a guess based on some
bulk okay
you show first since you're so confident
i'm
yeah kazakhstan yes oh kazakhstan is
huge
you know yes it is it is really good it
is damon island
uh that is also incorrect okay
the correct answer is vatican city
the vatican is its own country i didn't
know it was so small
i mean it's literally like two blocks oh
there can we go to the vatican city
kazakhstan that's what they said i'm
looking it up that's what they said in
the movie
what movie yeah not necessarily reliable
kazakhstan
they did the chasing of the jew in
kazakhstan do you remember that
yeah they don't do that that was fake
actually
yeah why would he do that then he's just
hating on himself i think it was meant
to be obviously a joke is he a
self-hating jew then
no what would that be called then
anti-semitic
he was just doing a pair it was a jail
could be called a joke
but when i do it it's anti-semitic yes
okay
noted got it so we are still tied up i'm
very uncomfortable with that please
proceed dan
yeah and i gotta crush you
here's one here's one for the americans
in the room what uh the statue of
liberty was a gift
from what country easy
france france that's right damn we're
killing it you're killing it we're
supposed to be against each other so
yeah no you're back to adam's category i
hate adam stanley category
no you're never gonna have them on this
well how am i gonna [ __ ] know what i
do
what kind of freaking nose is like oh i
don't how do i look next door to him i
know
i don't i didn't never went to the house
no i know i know the whereabouts
he lives near me yeah you want to go
camping no don't do that i do not want
to do that i just
i stumbled up across this information
everyone's house is house
his clothes staking at his house i don't
do that anymore
phone case i'm a fan and i'll go to his
house
i don't know how many fans are [ __ ]
buying my used clothes on ebay people
buy mine my mom sells them on poshmark
so keep buying them i don't know what my
closet is or something
your mom sells you use clothes to your
fan yeah but
she's just they're cheap does your mom
keep the money
um yeah she's just hustling you use
clothes
she just wants something to do people
like it people wanted me to sell all
these clothes that i just threw away so
she's interesting
she loves it shout out mom she loves
this shirt mom you want to sell my used
clothes
she would love to actually have some
she'll take it your mom
oh okay oh you want your mom to sell
yeah my mom maybe one looking for a
hobby
she's got some used clothes around that
she likes that she enjoy and people love
it people do unboxings on my clothes
people like do they prefer
unwashed or washed you have to wash them
you have to it's probably getting more
money if you don't
people make a whole bunch of videos like
i watch their periods of clothes they're
cheap too we don't like rip people off
like 500 for a t-shirt it's like five
bucks yeah it's fanfare it's like
give it a sniff i love buying people's
clothes so buy mine
okay interesting okay
i'm down to give your mom some of my
clothes i think it's funny okay
yeah she would love it she'd probably
just keep it it's like memorabilia
oh it's for the fans
this shirt this shirt was given to me by
ethan
they would love that people would really
love your clothes i love my the who you
gave me as little one of the things i
cherished so much i wear it all the time
i actually really love that hoodie that
you like cherish
no but i know you like the hoodie it's
not like that i wore it
it is didn't know that you interviewed
bobby lee in that
wow i'm a super fan i don't see my face
on your phone case
i come with it next time well yeah
that's what i don't know what i have in
secret
all right we're tied i'm uncomfortable
dan go ahead
i want one all right um your big-ass
hair is coming back to get you what
happened
your big-ass hair is getting stuck in
the mic it was actually the big-ass
diamond it hit the microphone and it
hurt me
oh my hair is huge it's getting stuck it
is hot my hair is very hot
it is oh yeah
[Laughter]
all right who was the first actor to
play
james bond on film oh i don't know that
some dude some old [ __ ] guy i feel
like i knew this
really i'm gonna do
not the right answer but i'm just gonna
guess
i misspelled it really bad so i'm going
to show you real fast sean connery
sean connery you both got it right we
did i thought there was someone before
there was like roger yeah there was some
duchenne roger moore was after sean
conrad
okay so hey look all right
i know but we're both doing really good
today yeah congrats congratulations
congratulations the podcast that's
canceled because of crystallia
say what his name is congratulations on
the podcast
oh okay but it should be called
cancellation cancelled right
or just miserable because that's what he
is look how big your hair is though
it's so big i know i really love it it's
awesome
it is awesome thanks
did you lose weight no it's just my hair
it's just my hair i thought you were
saying yes because i did it
it literally is just my hair um
five five this was the inspiration by
the way this is pamela anderson's big
hair
oh she did big hair mm-hmm sorry it was
great big hair queen and the black eye
so that's if anybody wants yeah it looks
really good thanks
you're rocking it thank you i like it
people just tell me i looked like pamela
anderson when i was on crack actually i
was like 140 pounds like
actually how was yours i looked like
pamela anderson if she gained 40 pounds
he said that on his show that's a
compliment
yeah kind of but not really i'll take it
down
okay go ahead all right what is the name
of the main
antagonist in happy gilmore
adam sam mean oh this is like english
too though what's an antagonist
was that the good guy or a bad guy uh
that would be the bad guy oh okay okay
the bad easy i'm sorry who knows that
i don't know it's a pretty popular one
no i don't know
or the character name uh i was asking
for the character name
okay if you know and boom bomb was
pointing if you know the actor i guess
i love the actor dude he hasn't been in
much time okay bob barker
that was a good guess well technically
he does get into a fight with bob barker
he's not the man he's not the main
antagonist
or gavin it is shooter mcgavin shooter
because it's embarrassing anyone who
watch happy gilmore that close hey
shooter you want to go to red line no
he's that's a it's a it's a that's a
classic villain right there
yeah they're doing a sequel and i want
to say it's because of me
i honestly think they're doing a happy
gilmore sequel because i have
i bought the jacket i talked about it i
got the hype up it's probably because
he's a
i don't want to call him a hack because
he's a good actor but his movies suck
and he sells them and makes a lot of
money movies
i'll invest in one if i can start one
can you back me up on that dan
what that he he's a hack it's
he's it's complicated because he has
legitimately made good movies
right he's an actor he can be
i love his dramatic roles he was great
in uncut gems and uh
punch trunk glove another one of my
favorite films right now but like
i mean how do you look past jack and
jill so good
my favorite app is actually don't say
that i love it
i can quote it pogo stop
i love that movie you stop i looked it
up before the show i'm gonna
i'm gonna lose because of this [ __ ]
adam sandler category
okay go ahead trish is winning adam
sandler
go ahead dan okay um
what is a geiger counter used to measure
uh geiger geiger that sounds
anti-semitic a geiger counter
so a bad what is a geiger a geiger
counter
a geiger counter yes i don't
i don't have a gag radio activity put me
on the board
that is the correct answer that's a nerd
hide up rather than that then the name
of [ __ ] adam sandler's
protagonist and happy gilmore antagonist
you know what i'm getting oh no i'm
getting all these people calling me out
like that i like adam sandler they call
me like dad they're like you're such a
dad for like adam sandler
like well he used to be so cool and hit
but now it's like embarrassing to like
him
i don't know i mean he has vid he's like
this big netflix deal and he's still
making like videos for kids
on netflix and i don't i don't assume
like he made that indian
cowboy one oh the hateful eight and i
was like
there's kind of only but it was like a
spin on it or something like but i was
like only kids would be watching this
because it's so dumb
yeah i love it you did no
okay so maybe you are okay thanks so
much
i don't know i just thought his movies
were so bad i mean with people oh my god
his comedy movies are so bad they're
just awful films
you're one of those people like those
who can't do hate that's you
i'm here doing what am i doing i'm not
making movies on netflix for a billion
dollars
i'm allowed to not like i'm a critic man
i [ __ ] [ __ ] on everybody adam
there's no exception just because you
like him yeah what happened 2021 ethan
doesn't stop [ __ ] on people just
like bringing people up and hyping
people up whoa when did i say
2020 that was you were 20 21 and i
thought we were on the same page
i never committed to any positive vibes
on the show
negative vibes only no we don't i
dispute that what can i say
is movies suck they're horrible they're
horrible
dude you're not coming to sat when i'm
on huey's halloween too you're not going
to be there
because but i like him as a person and
as a comedian i like him right and his
jewishness he promotes judaism a lot in
his movie that
doesn't the jewishness is not i love
factoring into my
likeness of him so that's what i'm
saying like i have ambivalent feelings
about him on one hand i like him under
the end his
comedy movies are horrible they're
[ __ ]
embarrassing well life converted so you
gained a jewish person in the community
that i don't consider a benefit to me
i'm always welcoming i'm not like
tracking the amount of jews in the world
and then i start my conversion classes
soon i need to start being serious yeah
i'm actually quite curious how that goes
for you i am too i don't know i'm
nervous
so i'm gonna like take it too far and
show up like all like
in like all crazy like wrapped up i
don't know where it's gonna take me
i don't show up with like a whole like a
old testament and you're gonna be
praying
to the western wall in jerusalem every
day can't wait
you'll be like girl you're taking this
way too far you're gonna become kosher
i am closure really
yeah okay what are you doing i'm waiting
for dan everything
i'm waiting for for an opening yeah all
right um
name three of the oceans
of the world oh my god these [ __ ]
you can't name three
i can name three but that's like easy
what am i an idiot
apparently dan thinks so
[Laughter]
you guys want to make it four it's just
one more yeah
it's just one more option yeah should be
easy right
okay i don't know i don't know the last
one let's do four yeah i've only been to
three oceans so i don't know the last
ocean
well it's not the la there's yes yeah
there it is
okay i don't know pacific atlantic
indian arctic
red that's a sea
that's a sea not an ocean i'm afraid i
don't know uh well
so you did have three but not four so
whoa and we did up it to four so oh my
god
i apologize sick you did it last minute
you were so cocky
you were so cocky i was not i was like
you're like what
so wait what's the score now ian am i up
by two seven six
okay yeah calm down right i tied it up
calm down calm down
[Applause]
more just don't worry just bring
whenever i'm in the lead just bring an
adam sandler question
i won't get one another one will be
coming around shortly um
what was the name of uh adam chandler's
love interest in the 1992
film water boy vicky valancourt
was that right freak he loves bees every
girl's name bee
veronica vaughn from billy madison vicki
valancourt from waterboy
what's uh drew barrymore's character in
uh wedding singer oh julia gullia
watching
julia ghoulia julia of course so stupid
i don't know any of this stuff and why
would i and he was robbie hart
why would anybody know these you know
why were you even around like he was so
popular for us like as kids like what
were you doing in the next few of his
films i mean
wasn't obsessing over adam sandler
really even with the hanukkah song
you're like oh finally someone wrote a
song
i listened to the hanukkah song i mean
you know what i mean it's like i don't
memorize every word i don't just tell
you
all right we're almost out of time so
let's just power a few with a few more
questions to give
trisha an opportunity to catch up here
okay um
all right another pop culture one um you
might know this
which character uh did audrey
hepburn play in breakfast at tiffany's
literally no idea
this is my answer nothing oh
oh oh oh no i know i don't know you know
yeah
holly go lightly you got it
good job that came out of nowhere
because i actually like didn't never saw
that movie but i knew her i
remember the name i would have expected
you to have been a fan
no i like marilyn i'm team blonde over
here
and now just ask a question about uh
adam sandler's
son we are
again but i will give you let's give one
that
at least ethan has a chance what was the
smell of adam sandler's fart was noted
by the uh his friend's character the
1992
film fartman returns wasn't there a
movie call for me i don't know
all right sounds like a title of a film
he'd make i know he's not a fart humor
kind of guy
literally that's the whole [ __ ] dude
jack and jill
jack and jill there was like a whole
five-minute scene where his
jill was in the bathroom just making
fart sounds and that was supposed to be
a hilarious moment and i was like
okay adam it was the chimichangas
[Laughter]
wow she ate mexican food and now she
can't stop pooping alleria
amazing writing adam sandler
okay guys i love it this is our last one
okay and then
next week we're starting with trivia
we're gonna hide are we tied we're
currently tied
right
what was the flavor of salsa on the
chimichanga burrito that made
jill fart uncontrollably in the 1997
classic jack and jill
97 but i don't know i'm just ripping him
i love it all right here we go which
adam sandler
film sees his character being extorted
while calling into a phone sex line wait
what can we say that i'm okay so that
what adam sandler film is about his
character being extorted
while calling into a phone sex line
you don't know it should i i mean i
don't know if i know it but i'm just
surprised because hey
what wait hold on why am i like blinking
can you say it one more time i'm so
sorry
is it adam sandler film and the story is
about
him his character he gets extorted
from calling into a phone sex line
i'm i like don't think i actually know
it okay i'm going to show myself
god i'm such a fake fan punch drunk love
that is correct i got it right you
haven't seen that movie
no oh it's like his best movie oh it's
so good him in a blazer like this right
isn't that history well it's like a
serious film it's not a comedy
and he didn't write it it's actually a
good movie you wouldn't like it
i would still say it's maybe it's a
little bit of a comic
like a really dark comedy i mean yeah
it's a serious role
that spanglish i refuse to watch i liked
spanglish
i watched and i you haven't pun struggle
it's legitimately one of his best movies
you gotta watch puncher
i hate the cover of it do better next
time trish is like sorry
trish is all of a sudden she's like
sorry actual serious film no thanks
well i'm sorry we're out of time and i
think ethan just won it on an adam
sandler question
oh that's not fair well it's okay we
have next week we're gonna pick up from
the top the score right now
is
so we will continue this battle uh
excellent comp
competitor i commend you and we'll
continue this uh next week
thank you it's my birthday week next
week i celebrate the whole week so i'm
very excited we're gonna show up in an
outfit you'll see
which one anyway
well i already said which one i think i
don't think it's a surprise but i don't
think we said it we did
not listen uh maybe not i am well anyway
we're going all out as usual
that's fun it's your birthday that'll be
fun we could do a little seance or
something maybe i'll be at your birthday
party we'll see
yeah i had some anxiety about inviting
you guys i don't know if you actually
want to come and it's like so awkward
i'd get rejected
but now that i know that there's like
squirt in your fountain i'm not so sorry
we have a security guard we have a
bartender we have a karaoke we're having
hibachi we're having like the hibachi
people come set up things like it's
gonna be cute
yeah wait what is hibachi is that like
the ball you throw it's like benihana
style
oh that's great i'm coming for food
really okay okay cool
it's gonna be fun don't try and show up
to my party we have security
at the at my house we hired extra
security that night because we would be
showing up to my house give them chicken
nuggets remember people have chicken
nuggets at our house today and there's
ants all over them don't do that
at your front door like on our gate by
our gate are you sure someone left the
nuggets maybe it was a random act of nug
leaving maybe it wasn't yeah
okay well don't leave me nugs i don't
want random acts and nugs
all right they're like here fatty
you always laugh when i said it off
camera and then when i do it on
oh random i wasn't expecting that though
okay
now i feel like an [ __ ] but you
always find it so fun life is funny it
just caught me out of god
well someone's like here here you're you
know there's some nuggets i'm not
here jew it's just random sorry it's not
being fat is not the same
as being a jewish i choose to be jewish
i'm converting so i'm choosing to be fat
because i'm eating
i don't know we're going but anyway i'm
sorry for the joke
i'm sorry i thought it was funny it's
random i have a high
so right thank you everybody we'll see
you next week we'll continue trivia
and be dressed up for trisha's birthday
peace and love
[Music]
you